तो चलिए आई थिंक वी नीड टू स्टार्ट नाउ
अ ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव लेट मी
चेक तो आ जाने देते
सबको ओके मैं वाइट बोर्ड ओपन कर लेता हूं
लेट मी ओपन द वाइट बोर्ड
एंड प्लीज टेल मी
गाइस इ एवरीथिंग विजिबल एंड ऑडिबल प्लीज
मुझे बता दीजिए आवाज जा रही है सबको
मेरी आवाज जा रही है सबको लेट मी सी हाउ
मेनी ऑफ यू हैव जॉइन राइट नाउ सो चलिए
काफी लोग ने जवाइन किया यहां पर
ओके जल्दी से जल्दी से आ जाइए फटाफट आ
जाइए यहां पर एंड ल स्टार्ट नाउ तो चलिए
आज की क्लास बहुत बहुत शानदार होने वाली
है बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाली है बहुत
कुछ सीखने को मिलने वाला है आपको बहुत कुछ
जानने को मिलने वाला है एंड आज का वन ऑफ द
मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट क्लास होने वाला है
समझना है आपको आज की क्लास में कुछ ऐसी
चीजें बताऊंगा जिसका इंपैक्ट आपके बग
बाउंट जर्नी में काफी ज्यादा तरी काफी ब
काफी ज्यादा होने वाला है काफी ज्यादा ठीक
है तो यहां पे अभी तक हमारे साथ 15 लोग
जुड़े हुए हैं चलिए बढ़िया है एंड बाकी
लोग भी जुड़ेंगे जल्दी से
ही मैं यहां पे एक मैसेज डाल देता
हूं चलिए सो 15 पीपल आर
हियर चलिए स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको
सिंपल सा कुछ सिंपल से कुछ आपको चीजें बता
देता हूं जो मैं ऑलवेज आपको बताता हूं एंड
एव्री वन हैव टू फॉलो इट राइट तो चलिए मैं
यहां पे अ ओपन कर लेता हूं यहां पे
एंड हियर
लेट्स न
[संगीत]
youtube0 की फ्री क्लासेस चल रही है एंड
लाइव सेक्शन में जब आप जाएंगे हमारे चैनल
के यहां पे
गुड गुड गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सब सबको
गुड इवनिंग यहां पे लाइव सेशन पे जाएंगे
तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं कि 20 लेक्चर
बग बाउंटीज के ऑलरेडी हमने कंप्लीट कर दिए
हैं यस वी हैव कंप्लीटेड 20 लेक्चर ऑलरेडी
ऑफ बग बाउंटीज एंड इन सारे लेक्चर को आपको
क्या करना है आपको देखना है कंप्लीट करना
है अगर आपका जो रह गया है उसको कंप्लीट
करना है एनीहाउ उसके बाद यह हमारी
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा हमारी कंपनी हमारे जो भी
हमारे स्टार्टअप से रिलेटेड जो भी अपडेट्स
होंगी नई फ्री कोर्सेस वगैरह या ट्रेनिंग
कुछ भी चीजें होंगी न्यू कोर्स लॉन्च होगा
अनाउंसमेंट होगा आपको इसी पेज पे जो है वो
देखने को मिलेगा उसके बाद ये हमारा
twittersignin.com हर एक जो भी हमारी
क्लासेस होती है उन क्लास की डिस्क्रिप्शन
में चेक कीजिएगा जैसे यह 208 जो हमारी
क्लास थी इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप जाएंगे
यहां पे इसको जब एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो यहां
पे आपको हमारे एक
हैकिंग की जिसमें कि हम बग बाउंट कर रहे
हैं बग बाउंट पढ़ रहे हैं सीख रहे हैं वो
आपको समझ में आ रहा होगा राइट तो मुझे एक
बार आप सब लोग बता दीजिए कि आप में से
कितने लोगों का कौन से डे पे डे तक हुआ है
मुझे कमेंट्स में बताइए गुड इवनिंग सबको
सबको नमस्ते मुझे आप लोग बताइए ठीक है ना
कि आप में से किन-किन का किन-किन डेज पे
कौन-कौन से डे पे आप अभी है कौन सा डे
आपका कंप्लीट हो चुका है या आपने पूरा ही
कंप्लीट कर लिया है कि आप डे वन पे है अभी
भी स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं या डे 10 डे 10 पे
है डे 15 पे है किस पे है मुझे कमेंट
बॉक्स में बता दीजिए जरा चैट में ताकि
मुझे थोड़ा सा आईडिया लग जाए राइट
चलिए प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस
अ ओके सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिएगा इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट
ओके डे 15 19 20 से 20 20 20 21
डेव डे 11 20
20 आपके बराबरी पर हूं शांके बहुत बढ़िया
चलो बहुत बढ़िया मतलब बहुत सारे लोगों का
मैं देख रहा हूं कि डे 2019 तक आ चुका है
ऑलमोस्ट राइट 15 से ऊपर है वो लोग तो बहुत
अच्छी बात है बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया ठीक
है सर मैं अभी 13 डे पर हूं तानिया ठीक है
ओके तानिया ओके ओके अहमद समझ गया
मैं ओके समझ गया मैं ओके गॉट
इट ग्रेट चलिए अच्छी बात है
[संगीत]
अ
ओके स्टार्ट ही हो गया है भाई स्टार्ट ही
हो गया है चलिए ओके देन बहुत बढ़िया आप सब
लोग प्लीज इट्स रिक्वेस्ट टू कंप्लीट ल द
डेज जितनी जल्दी हो सके एंड लाइव में
जुड़ा कीजिए ज्यादा मजा आता
है तो आज मैंने क्या किया है मैंने आज
वाइट बोर्ड ओपन करके रखा है एंड आप सबको
आज मैं बहुत ही ज्यादा एक इंपॉर्टेंट
टॉपिक कराने वाला हूं जिसका कि नाम है
एचटीटीपी हेडर्स
एचटीटीपी हेडर्स अब ये इंपॉर्टेंट कितना
इंपॉर्टेंट है एंड क्याक चीज हम इसके थ्रू
कर सकते हैं वह सब कुछ जानने वाले हैं ठीक
है देखो एचटीटीपी हेडर्स क्या होता है एंड
इसका रोल बग बाउंट में क्या है यह समझना
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है ठीक है मैं इसका
आपको एक लाइव एग्जांपल दिखाना चाहता हूं
लाइव एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं बग
क्राउड प चलता हूं
पहले बक क्राउड प चलते हैं प्रोग्राम पे
और कितने वीडियोस आएंगे सर अभी वीडियोस
आती रहेंगी कम से कम 6 महीने
तक कम से कम सिक्स मंथ्स तक आपके वीडियोस
आती
रहेगी बक क्राउड प हम आ जाते हैं हम बक
क्राउड प है अब मैं क्या करता हूं आई एम
गोइंग टू ओपन बब शूट लेट्स ओपन बब
शूट चलिए यहां पे मैं बप शूट को रन कर
देता
हूं एंड इस वाले को हम ओपन कर लेते हैं
अपने फ फॉक्स
ब्राउजर ओके सो वी हैव बब शूट ऑन नाउ हम
यहां से यहां से कोई भी एक प्रोग्राम चूज
कर लेते हैं कोई भी प्रोग्राम चलेगा कोई
भी प्रोग्राम रैपिड यह प्रोग्राम हम चूज
कर लेते हैं ठीक है इस प्रोग्राम के बहुत
सारे डोमस है इसके स्कोप में तो हम इसमें
से कोई भी एक स्कोप डोमेन जो है उठा लेते
हैं जैसे रप नेट इसको हमने उठा लिया अब हम
क्या करते हैं हम इसको यहां पर ओपन कर
लेते हैं इस डोमेन को ओबवियसली यहां पर ये
ओपन हो जाएगा एंड ट्स इट ठीक है बस अब हम
क्या करते हैं यहां से हम फॉक्सी प्रॉक्सी
से बब शूट का जो प्रॉक्सी है वह सेलेक्ट
कर लेते हैं यहां पर हमने सेलेक्ट कर लिया
एंड नाउ वी शुड रीलोड द वेबसाइट सो दैट इट
कम्स इन द टारगेट पब हियर टारगेट में
हमारा यह बेसिकली आ जाएगा डड n यह रहा
r.net य हमारा जो टारगेट है यहां पर आ
चुका है ठीक है अब हम इसको ऐड टू स्कोप कर
देते हैं एंड यहां पर फिल्टर में शो इन
स्कोप आइटम्स ओनली कर देते हैं ताकि हमें
सिर्फ रड नेट वेबसाइट दिखे फालतू की जो
रिजल्ट्स है वो हमें ना दिखे ठीक है
अब अब मैं आपको एक चीज दिखाता
हूं अब आप देखिए एंड देन आपको ज्यादा
क्लियर समझ में आ जाएगा ठीक
है चलिए ये रनेट है यहां पे एंड जैसे ही
रड नेट यहां पे मैंने यहां ओपन करा इसमें
हम हमारे लाइक टारगेट लिस्ट में आया तो
आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पर आपका टारगेट है
यह कंटेंट टैब है जहां पर आपके पैरामीटर्स
यूआरएल स्टेटस के बारे में पता चलता है
एंड जस्ट उसके नीचे यहां पर आपको दो
ऑप्शंस दिख रहे हैं एक रिक्वेस्ट का और एक
रिस्पांस का इसको बोलते हैं रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर जो यह आपको दिख रहा है यह जो है ना
यह यह जो आपको दिख रही है यह
कुकीज यह आपको जो दिख रही है ये यह
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स है ठीक है एंड यहां पर
आपको दिख रहा है रिस्पांस यह आपके क्या है
रिस्पांस हेडर्स
है यह जो है आपके क्या है रिस्पांस हेडर्स
यह जो आपको दिख रहे हैं राइट दिस आर
रिस्पांस डर अब ये रिक्वेस्ट हेडर एंड
रिस्पांस हेडर्स क्या है
तो एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के अंदर ही दो हेडर्स
आपको देखने को मिल जाते हैं बेसिकली मैं
बोलूंगा तीन हेडस देखने को मिल जाते हैं
एक आपका जनरल हेडस देखने को मिल जाता है
एक
आपकी रिक्वेस्ट हेडर देखने को मिल जाता है
एंड एक जो है आपका वह रिस्पांस हेडर देखने
को मिल जाता
है ठीक है अब आप यह सोच रहे होगे
कि कि रिस्पांस हेडर एंड रिक्वेस्ट हेडर
इन दोनों की क्यों रिक्वायरमेंट है क्या
रिक्वायरमेंट ट रिमेंट ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट हेडर
रिस्पांस हेडर कहां से आया भाई ये चीज जब
तुम बग बाउंटीज करते हो तो बग्स फाइंड
करते हो इंफॉर्मेशन डिस्क्लोजर की वर्क
फाइंड कर लिया एक्सस फाइंड कर लिया
सीएसआरएफ फाइंड कर लिया या लाइक स्मग ए
सटी प स्मगलिंग कर रहे हो या व्हाट एवर जो
भी तुम चीजें वेब वेब सॉकेट की लेबिलिटी
फाइंड करने की वेब सॉकेट का यूज करके उसके
अंदर कोई वने एबिलिटीज वेब सॉकेट लेबिलिटी
फाइंड कर रहे हो या जीरा व्हाट एवर जो भी
आप करना चाह रहे हो वो आप कर रहे हो अब
मैं आपको यह बोलूं कि अगर आपको एचटीटीपी
हेडर्स की प्रॉपर नॉलेज है तो आप एक
प्रोग्राम में जहां आपने फाइ वैलिड बग्स
फाइंड किए हैं आपको वहां पर 10 वैलिड बग्स
मिल सकते
हैं यह ग्रोथ आपके पॉसिबल है ड्यू टू
एसटीडीपी हेडस नॉलेज जस्ट
नॉलेज मैं आपको यह बोलू कि इस एसटीटीपी
हेडर में यह रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के अंदर में
यहां पर जो होस्ट हेडर यहां पर आपको दिख
रहा है इसके नीचे में यहां पर मैं कुछ
एंट्रीज करके मैं इसको क्या करता हूं सेंड
टू रिपीटर कर देता हूं रिक्वेस्ट हेडर को
रिपीटर पर चलते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां पर
मैं इसको गो प क्लिक करता हूं यहां आपको
रिस्पांस आ जाएगा अब आपको बिल्कुल क्लियर
क्लियर दिख रहा होगा कि यह रिक्वेस्ट हेडर
है यह रिस्पांस हेडर है राइट अब मैं आपको
यह बोलू कि यहां होस्ट के नीचे मान लो मैं
यहां पर एक एंटर करता हूं एंड यहां पर मैं
एक ओरिजिन डालता ह कोई भी ओरिजिन एक जि
डालता हूं मैं एल कॉ एंड इससे मैं इस
वेबसाइट को हैक कर लेता हूं मैं इस
वेबसाइट में बग फाइंड कर लेता हूं तो आपको
कैसा लगेगा बहुत ही अजूबा लगेगा राइट मैं
आपको यह बोलू कि यह जो यूजर एजेंट है यह
यूजर एजेंट यहां पे मैं यहां पर इस यूजर
एजेंट में कुछ ऐसी एंट्रीज करूं कि मुझे
एक बग मिल जाए तो आपको कैसा लग
बहुत ही अजूबा लगेगा अब यह पावर है हेडर्स
के अंदर की मिस कॉन्फिन की मैं आपको यह
बोलू कि यह आपका हेडर रिक्वेस्ट हेडर गेट
गेट रिक्वेस्ट हेडर है यहां पे गेट मेथड
गेट एचटीटीपी मेथड यूज कर रहा है और मैं
इसको राइट क्लिक करके एंड चेंज यहां पर
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड करके पोस्ट कर दूं और इससे
एक लेबिलिटी फाइंड कर लू तो कैसा लगेगा
अजूबा लगेगा मैं आपको यह बोलूं कि इस
पर्टिकुलर रिस्पांस हेडर के अंदर में यहां
पे आप ये जो रिस्पांस हेडर है इसके अंदर
में मैं एक हेडर लगा दूं एक रिस्पांस हेडर
लगा दूं जो
कि जो कि ये होगी
सेट कुकी सेट कुकी या इसको हाइ फन दे दें
इसको वैसे दे देंगे हाइ फन दे देंगे सॉरी
हाइ फन सेट कुकी एंड यहां पे सेट कुकी एंड
यहां पर मैं कुछ ऐसी चीजें एंटर कर दूं
जिससे कि आपको बग मिल जाए तो फिर कैसा
लगेगा राइट अब यह सारी चीजें आप इन दोनों
की नॉलेज से सीख सकते हैं बट इसके लिए
आपको पता होना चाहिए कि यह पोस्ट क्या है
गेट क्या है यह होस्ट क्या है यह ओरिजिन
क्या है यूजर एजेंट क्या है एक्सेप्ट
लैंग्वेज क्या है कुकी क्या है फिर आपको
पता होना चाहिए कि ये एक्स फ्रेम क्या है
सर्वर क्या है एक्स पावर्ड बाय क्या है है
एक्स कंटेंट टाइप क्या है कंटेंट
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी क्या है हालांकि सीएसपी
के बारे में मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको बताया हुआ
था ठीक है तो यह सारी जानकारी जब आपके पास
होगी तो जब आप बग्स फाइंड कर रहे होंगे
वनबिल फाइंड कर रहे होंगे पर्टिकुलर किसी
टारगेट के अंदर में तो आपके वहां माइंड जो
आप चला रहे होंगे व माइंड और ज्यादा चलने
लगेगा और ज्यादा चीजें आप एक्सप्लोर कर
पाएंगे इन हेडर्स के थ्रू एंड इनको हम
बोलते हैं एचटीटीपी हेडर्स एंड इनका बहुत
बड़ा रोल है इन योर बग बाउंट जर्नी अगर
आपको इनके बारे में नहीं पता डेफिनेटली यू
आर मिसिंग सम वेरी क्रिटिकल बग्स बहुत
सारे क्रिटिकल बग्स आप मिस कर दोगे पुट
हेडर सॉरी पुट एसटीटीपी मेथड जो कि
अपलोडिंग के लिए यूज में जनरली किया जाता
है स्टोर अपलोड करके कोई चीज स्टोर करनी
हो उसकी वल बिलिटी के कारण आप बहुत तरह की
फाइल अपलोड वलन बिलिटी को एक्सप्लोइट कर
सकते हैं एंड देर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स तो जब
हम मान लो फाइल अपलोड लेबिलिटी को पढ़ रहे
उस टाइम आपको पुट के बारे में नहीं पता
आपको कोई मतलब नहीं है फिर समझ में नहीं
आएगा कि पुट क्या होता है समझ नहीं आएगा
सो दिस आर कॉल्ड एसटीटीपी हेडर्स थैंक यू
आरसी
टेक या राइट इनको
गक मजा आ जाएगा सर मजा आएगा ना यस आज तो
ज्यादा मजा आएगा बिल्कुल मजा आएगा बहुत
ज्यादा मजा आएगा चलिए अब एचटीटीपी हेडर्स
में हम यहां पर पहले बात करेंगे एचटीटीपी
के बारे में
अब इसके बारे में बहुत लोग आप में से सारे
लोग मोस्टली जानते होंगे जिसका फुल फॉर्म
होता है हाइपर टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल
ठीक है इसका फुल फॉर्म आपको पता है हाइपर
टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल ठीक है ए सिंपल एजट इसका एक
सिंपल सा आपको डेफिनेशन मैं यहां पर बता
देता हूं बहुत ही सिंपल सा डेफिनेशन है
हाइपरटेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल इज द कोर
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल यूज टू एक्सेस द
वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब एंड इज यूज्ड बाय ऑल ऑफ द
टुडेज वेब एप्लीकेशन सिंपल सा फंडा है एक
कोर कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है जिसका यूज
करके वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब को एक्सेस किया जाता
है डडड को आप यहां पर एक्सेस कर रहे होते
हैं दिस इज कॉल्ड
एचटीटीपी इसको हम क्या बोलते हैं एचटीटीपी
जो कि एक सिंपल कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है
अब एचटीटीपी के साथ यहां
पर
इसको मैं डिलीट कर देता
हूं अब
एचटीटीपी के साथ आपने एचटीटी पी एस के
बारे में भी सुना होगा एचटीटीपीएस कुछ भी
नहीं है बस एचटीटीपी ही है इसके साथ एक एस
जुड़ा हुआ है एंड दिस एस स्टैंड
फॉर
सिक्योर सॉकेट्स
लेयर यानी कि यह सिक्योर लिखा हुआ है एस
एस एल तो इस एस का मतलब होता है सिक्योर
सॉकेट्स लेयर एंड इसी एसएसएल का एक
सक्सेसर अब आता है जो कि यूज होता है वो
है टीएल एस ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सिक्योरिटी
आप बोल सकते हैं ऐसे सेल को आप सिक्योर
सॉकेट लेयर बोल सकते हैं बस और आज की
क्लास वही करेंगे जिनको एक्चुअल समझना है
जिनको एक्चुअल नॉलेज लेनी है ना कांसेप्ट
के बारे में मुझे पता है वो आज की क्लास
छोड़ नहीं सकते हैं क्योंकि इतना मजेदार
होने वाला
ठीक है समझ में आ रहा
है कोई बात नहीं आरसी टेक दिव्यांश मिश्रा
नो
इशू अब एसटीटीपी तो आपको पता है एक
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल
है टू एक्सेस डडड वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब
एचटीटीपीएस इसी का सिक्योर वर्जन
है यह पोर्ट नंबर 80 पे काम करता है यह
पोर्ट नंबर 443 पे ऑपरेट करता है बस
एसएसएल यूज होती थी बहुत टाइम से हमारी इस
एसटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल एसटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल के
बाद के तर के द्वारा एसएसएल बट अब बहुत
सारे वेब एप्लीकेशंस जो है बहुत सारी लाइक
जगह पे सॉरी वेब एप्लीकेशन की बात नहीं कर
रहा मैं अब एसएसएल की जगह पे वी आर यूजिंग
मोस्ट मोस्टली टी एलएस तो मोस्टली जो है
वह टी एलएस अब यूज हो रहा है ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर सिक्योरिटी अब एसएसएल एंड टी एलएस इन
दोनों के बारे में थोड़ा सा समझ ले इसके
लिए मेरे पास एक विजुअल रिप्रेजेंटेशन है
आपके लिए सिक्योर सॉकेट लेयर एंड टी एलएस
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
सिक्योरिटी यह एसएसएल डेवलप किया गया था
नेट स्केप कम्युनिकेशन नेट स्केप के
कम्युनिटी के तरफ से नेट स्केप के द्वारा
यह डेवलप किया गया था टी एलएस जो है वह
डेवलप किया गया था आईईटीएफ के द्वारा ठीक
है इंटरनेट इंजीनियरिंग टास्क फोर्स
एसएसएल को 1995 में रिलीज किया गया था
वर्जन 2.0 एंड जो टी था इसको 1999 में
रिलीज किया गया था एसएसएल में तीन वर्जन
थे जो कि टूथ थे टीएल एस में चार वर्जन है
टी एलएस 1.1 टी एलएस 1.2 1.1 1.2 1.3 चार
वर्जन जितने भी एसएसएल के वर्जन है सबको
डिपट किया गया सबको अब यूज नहीं किया जाता
है क्योंकि सारे वल्नरेबल थे बाय डिजाइन
वल्नरेबल थे बहुत सारी सिक्योरिटी फ्लज थी
टी एलएस व एंड 1.1 इन दोनों को हटाया गया
इन दोनों को यूज नहीं किया जाता है मोस्ट
ऑफ द सिक्योर वेब एप्लीकेशंस के द्वारा बट
लए 1.2 एंड 1.3 इज बीइंग यूज्ड
करेंटली यहां पे एसएसएल एक पोर्ट का यूज
करता था कनेक्शन बनाने के लिए यहां पे टी
एलएस जो है वो एक प्रोटोकॉल का यूज करता
है दोनों में डिफरेंस है एसएसएल मैसेज
ऑथेंटिकेशन कोड का यूज करता है टू
ऑथेंटिकेट मैसेजेस बट टी एलएस हैश मैसेज
ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल का यूज करता है कोड
का यूज करता है जो कि एक हैश फॉर्मेट में
होता है तो थोड़ा ज्यादा आपका सिक्योरिटी
यहां पर हो जाता है ठीक है सर वॉल्यूम
इंक्रीज इंक्रीज कर दीजिए वॉल्यूम कम जा
रही है क्या यार मुझे तो ऐसा नहीं लगता कि
वॉल्यूम कम जानी चाहिए लेट मी सी वॉल्यूम
वॉल्यूम तो सही है मेरे साइड से इंक्रीज
ही है आई डोंट नो शायद आपके साइड कुछ कम आ
रही होगी सो मुझे आप लोग बता दीजिए
वॉल्यूम सही है
क्या वॉल्यूम कम है
क्या
मेरे तो यार बहुत अच्छी वॉल्यूम आ रही है
मैं अपने फोन में भी चेक किया
मैंने बहुत वॉल्यूम आ रही है मुझे बता
दीजिए सभी लोग बताइए
प्लीज वॉल्यूम इज गुड और क्योंकि मेरे को
मेरे फोन में वॉल्यूम अच्छी आ रही है
ज्यादा आ रही
है साउंड ओके ठीक
है
ओके ठीक है सर
ठीक
है ओके ओके ओके फोन की वॉल्यूम थोड़ा बढ़ा
दीजिए अगर पॉसिबल है तो फोन की वॉल्यूम को
मैक्सिमम करके रखिए ट्राई कीजिए ठीक है
चलिए तो यह आपने एसएसएल एंडटी एलएस के
बारे में समझ लिया ठीक है अब ये एसएसएल
एक्चुअली था क्या एसएसएल एक्चुअली में
क्या था ये
एसएसएल ये एक
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक एक क्रिप्टोग्राफिक
मैकेनिज्म
है टू
सिक्योर द डेटा
बंग
ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर द
नेटवर्क यह क्या है यह क्रिप्टोग्राफिक
मैकेनिज्म है क्रिप्टोग्राफिक मैकेनिज्म
है आपका एसल जिसका यूज किया जाता है वैसे
डाटा को सिक्योर करने के लिए जो ओवर द
नेटवर्क ट्रांसमिट कर रहे होते हैं ठीक है
इसलिए यूज किया जाता है एसएसएल या एसएसएल
इंक्रिप्शन अब यह किस तरीके का इंक्रिप्शन
होता है मैं आपको पहले यह दिखा देता हूं
नॉर्मल इंक्रिप्शन की जब बात करते हैं तो
हम यहां पे यह हमारा क्लाइंट
है एंड यह हमारा सर्वर
है राइट क्लाइंट सर्वर से बात करता है
सर्वर क्लाइंट को रिस्पांस करता है यह
रिक्वेस्ट हो जाती है यह रिस्पांस हो जाता
है राइट क्लाइंट उसको वापस से क्या कर
देता है एक्नॉलेज कर देता
है अब इसके बीच में डाटा ट्रांसमिट हो रही
होती है अब अगर हम यहां पर इंक्रिप्शन यूज
कर रहे हैं तो जो डाटा यहां से निकल के आ
रही है और जो डाटा यहां तक जा रही है इसको
यह क्या कर देता है इंक्रिप्ट कर देता
है यह आपका इनक्रिप्टेड डाटा हो जाता है
बट अगर कोई अटैक डायरेक्टली सर्वर पर हो
रहा है या क्लाइंट प हो रहा है इससे
एसएसएल सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइड नहीं करती है
याद रखिएगा एसएसएल डोंट प्रोवाइड
सिक्योरिटी टू द डायरेक्ट अटैक्स ऑन
क्लाइंट मशीन और सर्वर मशीन यह
मिसकनसेप्शन है बहुत लोगों का कि एसएसएल
है अगर कोई वेबसाइट में जैसे यह
मिसकनसेप्शन क्या है कि अगर मेरी वेबसाइट
है fix.com जो कि अभी मेंटेनेंस में है
बिकॉज इसमें कुछ काम चल रहा है तो यह
वेबसाइट है एचटीटीपीएस पे यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे कि वी आर यूजिंग कनेक्शन
इ सिक्योर आपको दिख रहा होगा सर्टिफिकेट
जो है यूज हो रही है एचटीटीपीएस यूज हो
रहा है तो इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि
डेनिक्स कंपलीटली सिक्योर है बिकॉज वी आर
यूजिंग इंक्रिप्शन या एसएसएल एसटीपीएस
नहीं डायरेक्ट अटैक सर्वर पे हो क्लाइंट प
हो वह सिक्योरिटी एसएसएल नहीं देता
बिल्कुल भी सिर्फ ओवर द नेटवर्क
ट्रांसमिटेड डाटा को इनक्रिप्ट करने के
लिए यूज में लिया जाता है ट्स इट ये
एसएसएल होती है चलिए अब आते हैं मुद्दे पे
फिर से वापस
से तो यह आपने समझ लिया एचटीटीपी क्या
होता है यह आपने समझ लिया एचटीटीपी एस
क्या है एंड एसएसएल क्या है उसका सक्सेसर
टी एलएस है यह सब कुछ आपको समझ में आ गया
राइट
अब एक बार मेरा नाम ले
लीजिए लॉजस कुमार
ग्रेट ठीक है ग्रेट अब यहां पे हम बात कर
रहे थे एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के बारे
में ठीक है तो चलिए एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के
बारे में थोड़ा हम समझते हैं थोड़ा हम
जानते हैं एंड व हेडर्स कौन से हैं वह
आपको मैंने ऑलरेडी बताया यह रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स हैं जो आपको यहां पे दिख रहे हैं
इस साइड जो आपको दिख रहे हैं रिस्पांस
हेडर्स है या आप टारगेट टैब में आएंगे बब
शूट के तो यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट पैरामीटर में
रिक्वेस्ट वाली हेडर्स यहां पे दिख जाएंगी
रिस्पांस वाले में यहां पे रिस्पांस हेडर
जो है आपको वो दिख जाता है तो इसको आप
समझते हैं बढ़िया से ठीक है क्या सर जी
बड़े-बड़े वेबसाइट्स में कुछ अजीब ही
हेडर्स होते हैं समझ में नहीं आता है हां
बहुत सारे हेडर्स हैं बहुत सारे हेडर्स जो
आपने नहीं देखे होंगे वह भी आपको मिल
जाएंगे बहुत सारी वेबसाइट्स में आपको उनके
बारे में थोड़ा समझना पड़ेगा जानना पड़ेगा
ठीक है उनके बारे में जब आप जान जाएंगे तो
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा एंड उसके अकॉर्डिंग
आप उसमें चेंजेज करके ट्राई कर सकते हैं
कोई मिस कन्फेशन फाइंड करने की कैसे हैं
आप बढ़िया हूं मैं
चलिए तो अब हम आते हैं यहां पर मैं आ गया
इस वाले नोट्स के ऊपर जो मेरी नोट्स है
यहां पर एंड मैं क्या कर देता हूं मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा जूम इन कर लेता हूं लेट्स
जूम इन ताकि आपको क्लियर दिख जाए य ओके अब
यहां पर हम एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट के बारे
में थोड़ा सा हम बात करते हैं एसटीडीपी
रिक्वेस्ट क्या है उसको थोड़ा सा समझ देते
हैं ठीक है यह जो दोनों आपको दिख रहा है
यह रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर तो
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर जो है एटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
का ही पार्ट है ठीक है आपका रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर उसी का रिस्पांस मिलता है रिस्पांस
हेडर के थ्रू सर्वर के साइड से ए सिपल ठीक
है ओके आई वाज अ ग्राफिक्स
डिजाइनर नाउ आई एम लर्निंग ब बग हंटिंग
योर कोर्स इज टॉप नॉच आई वुड लाइक टू
क्रिएट फ्री थंबनेल्स फॉर द रेस्ट ऑफ योर
कोर्स आई हैव सेंड द डिटेल्स
एंड सैंपल्स ऑन लिंकन ओके एनन बिल थैंक यू
सो मच ब्रदर फॉर दिस अह थिंग एंड
डेफिनेटली आई विल गेट बैक टू यू ऑन
linkedinsign.com मोटिवेशन देगा एंड आपके
लिए वो बहुत अची अचीवमेंट बड़ी अचीवमेंट
होनी चाहिए आप उसको छोटी अचीवमेंट की तरह
ट्रीट मत कीजिए बहुत सारे मेरे स्टूडेंट्स
है जो अभी बग बाउंटीज कर रहे हैं काफी
सारी अचीवमेंट ऑलरेडी दे आर कलेक्टिंग
उनको बाउंटीज हल ऑफ फेम सब मिल रहा है ठीक
है तो आपको भी मिलेगा याद रखिएगा अब बात
करते हैं य पे एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट के बारे
में क्या होता है एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट क्या
होता है सिंपल यार वही कुछ नहीं यह जो
क्लाइंट है यह जो सर्वर है यह जो
रिक्वेस्ट है रिक्वेस्ट क्लाइंट भेजता
सर्वर को इसी को हम एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
बोलते हैं क्योंकि एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल का
यूज करके वेब को एक्सेस कर वर्ल्ड वाइड
वेब को तो जो रिक्वेस्ट भेजी जा रही है
उसको हम एटीपी रिक्वेस्ट बोलते हैं सिंपल
तो ल एचटीटीपी मैसेजेस रिक्वेस्ट एंड
रिस्पांसस कंसिस्ट ऑफ वन और मोर हेडर्स च
ऑन सेपरेट लाइन फॉलो बाय अ मैंडेटरी
ब्लैंक लाइन फॉलो बाय एन ऑप्शनल मैसेज
बॉडी एक मैसेज बॉडी भी होता है जो कि
ऑप्शनल है अ टिपिकल एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट इज
एज
फॉलोज ठीक
है ओके एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट टिपिकल क्या
होगा इस तरीके का आपको दिखेगा ये जो आपको
यहां पे दिख रहा है जिसमें गेट ये एक चीज
होगी गेट ठीक है जहां पे आपको पता चलेगा
कि कौन सा एचटीटीपी मेथड यूज हो रहा है
करेंटली उसके बाद एक पाथ आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिलेगा कि किस पाथ के लिए
रिक्वेस्ट किस पाथ को एक्सेस करने के लिए
कौन सी सोर्स एक्सेस करने के लिए यह
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी जा रही है सर्वर के साइड
सर्वर पर कौन सी ऐसी रिसोर्स है जिसको
यूजर या क्लाइंट एक्सेस करना चाहता है
उसकी डिटेल्स आपको यहां मिलती है फर्स्ट
लाइन के सेकंड वाले कॉलम उसके बाद आपको
एचटीटीपी का वर्जन देखने को मिल जाता है
जो कि यहां पर एटीटीपी 1.1 है थर्ड कॉलम
ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पर आपको अलग-अलग
हेडर्स देखने को मिल जाते हैं जिसके बारे
में भी हम डिस्कस करने वाले अब पहली बार
जब आप रिक्वेस्ट क्रिएट करते हैं या जब भी
रिक्वेस्ट आप सेंड करते हैं स्टडी प
रिक्वेस्ट तो जो फर्स्ट लाइन
है उसमें तीन कॉलम्स मैंने आपको बताए उनके
बारे में जान लेते हैं पहला कॉलम गेट यह
क्या होता है द वर्ब इंडिकेटिंग द
एचटीटीपी मेथड अब एसटीटीपी मेथड्स बहुत
सारे होते हैं गेट पोस्ट पुट डिलीट बहुत
सारे उसी में का यह एक एचटीटीपी मेथड है
गेट द मोस्ट कॉमनली यूज्ड मेथड इज गेट हुज
फंक्शन इज टू रिट्रो फ्रॉम द वेब सर्वर
गेट रिक्वेस्ट डू नॉट हैव ए मैसेज बॉडी
इनका कोई मैसेज बॉडी नहीं होता है सो नो
फर्द डेटा फॉलोज द ब्लैंक लाइन आफ्टर द
मैसेज हेडर्स
सिंपल देन आपका आता है यूआरएल अ यूआरएल
क्या होती है ये देखिए द रिक्वेस्टेड
यूआरएल द यूआरएल टिपिकली फंक्शन एस अ नेम
फॉर द रिसोर्स बीइंग
रिक्वेस्टेड जो रिसोर्स रिक्वेस्ट कर रही
है बस उसी का वहां पे पाथ या डिटेल दिया
हुआ रहता है विथ एन ऑप्शनल क्वेरी
स्ट्रिंग कंटेनिंग पैरामीटर्स दैट इज द
क्लाइंट इज पासिंग टू दैट रिसोर्स एक
पैरामीटर होना चाहिए होना होता है जो कि
मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ जैसे ये
यूआईडी पैरामीटर अब ये पैरामीटर के बारे
में पता है तो आपको यूआईडी दिख रहा है जब
यूआईडी दिख गई तो आपको आईडी आर दिख जाना
चाहिए अरे यार यहां आईडी आर वल बिलिटी हो
सकती है इनसिक्योर डायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
रिफरेंस समझे तो हेडर्स की जानकारी होगी
ना तो बग्स की भी नॉलेज एंड उसके ऊपर काम
करने का मजा कुछ अलग ही आपको आने वाला है
ठीक कुछ अलग ही मजा आने वाला यह देखिए यह
कोई आ रहे हैं और चैट में बोल रहे हैं डि
फोनिक्स स्कैमर ठीक है
इनको इनको इनको क्या करते क्या होता है कि
एक्चुअली कुछ लोग होते हैं जैसे मैं इनका
भी मैसेज डिलीट नहीं करूंगा ताकि सब लोगों
को पता चले कुछ लोग ऐसे होते हैं जिनकी
अभी के टाइम में ना बग बाउंटीज की फ्री
कोर्सेस जो चल रहे हैं इनसे उनकी जली पड़ी
हुई है बहुत भयानक वाली ऐसी खतरनाक जली
पड़ी है जिसका कोई एंड नहीं है इनफा वे
में जला हुआ है वो लोग क्या करते हैं अपने
कुछ बंदे भेज देते हैं लाइव में कि भाई
जाओ वहां थोड़ा बहुत स्पैम करो थोड़ा लिख
दो बस हो गया स्कम यह नहीं बताएंगे और कुछ
नहीं स्कम ए सिंपल और मैं जो भी स्कैमर
बोलते हैं मैं उनको सीधा सधा यही बात
बोलता हूं कि अगर कोई स्कैम हमने किया है
तो कम विथ अ प्रूफ सॉलिड प्रूफ क्योंकि
अगर प्रूफ के साथ नहीं आओगे तो भाई मैं
तुम्हारी बैंड बजा दूंगा इतना पावर है
मेरे अंदर सिंपल सा फंडा है इतना पावर है
कि अगर मुझे पता चल जाए या पता कर भी लूं
तो तुम्हारी बैंड बजनी
लेकिन लेकिन ऐसे आके ग्रुप मतलब ये चैट
में इस तरह से कुछ भी लिख देना किसी के
कहने पे आके कुछ लोग जैसे कोई होगी दूसरी
कंपनीज के दूसरे जो राइवल्स हैं या जो
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी के है जिनकी
बैंड बजी पड़ी है इस फ्री को कि उनको
दिखने को लग रहा है ना यार कि इस बंदे के
मतलब कंपनी इसके इनके सिर्फ 12000
फॉलोअर्स हैं एंड एंड उसमें इतने
इंगेजमेंट्स हैं इतने सारे लोग जुड़ रहे
हैं इनके लाइव में इतना कुछ कर रहे हैं
हाउ इ इट इज पॉसिबल इतना अच्छा अट्रैक्शन
मिल रहा है इतना अच्छा वो मिल रहा है इनके
वीडियोस पे हाउ इट इज
पॉसिबल तो यह इसके कारण से इनकी थोड़ी सी
हिल गई है इनका क्या होता है जैसे इनका भी
फिर दिमाग भी हिल गया है राइट तो वही
यात्रा करने यहां पे आ जाते हैं ठीक है
वैसे ही सेम चीज सेम चीज बस तो बस ज्यादा
नहीं कुछ बोलूंगा सिंपल सा ब्लॉक लिस्ट
में डाल देता हूं मैं ज्यादा क्या करूंगा
मैं टाइम आउट में डाल देता हूं बट ऐसे
करने से कोई फायदा होने वाला नहीं है मेरा
कुछ बिगड़ेगा भी नहीं और ना ही मैं यहां
पे अ आप जो चीजें मैं करा रहा हूं उससे
मैं ना रुकने वाला हूं कुछ भी कर लो आई एम
नॉट गोइंग टू स्टॉप व्हाट एवर यू यू डिड
आई एम नॉट गोइंग टू स्टॉप राइट किसी भी
तरीके से बस चलिए तो यह थोड़ा सा देखिए ये
थोड़ा सा फिर भी टाइम हमारा यूटिलाइज हो
गया इसमें बट इसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
आप लोगों को थोड़ा सा टाइम बीच में
क्योंकि देना पड़ता है क्योंकि एक वही चीज
है जो हम बिल्कुल भी नहीं करते एंड वो है
स्कैमिंग बिल्कुल भी नहीं क्योंकि हम खुद
दूसरों के स्कैमिंग से बचाते हैं एंड
ट्राई करते हैं स्कैमर्स की बैंड बजाने की
एंड यह मैंने बहुत पहले भी करा हुआ है
बहुत टाइम बहुत कभी-कभी बीच में कर ही
देता हूं तो आना है यार अगर जो भी आना है
आपको अगर मुझे या हमें स्कैमर बोलना है तो
रियल आईडी से बोल के दिखाओ रियल एकदम जो
रियल बंद जो है जिसे पहचाना जा सके और
अपनी कांटेक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन दो रियल नंबर दो
फिर देखते हैं कौन स्कैमर है या कौन क्या
करता है राइट ये तो खुली धमकी दे रहा हूं
मैं आपको जो भी यहां पे आके स्पैम कर रहे
थे खुली धमकी है भाई ये ये रखना चैलेंज है
ये ये नहीं बोला कि मैं रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा
हूं कि भाई पब्लिक देख रही है तो कैसे ऐसे
बोल सकते हैं ना ना पब्लिक देख रही है तो
पब्लिक को भी पता है यार खुली फुला छुट्टा
धमकी चलो आ जाओ बस
दैट्ची डिस्टर्ब करोगे तो यार बेकार है
ठीक है चलिए
ओके ओके चलिए तो अभी चलते हैं ज्यादा
डिस्टर्ब नहीं होते हैं वापस से बैक टू द
टॉपिक आ जाते हैं बीच में थोड़ा सा
डिस्टरबेंस हो गया अब बिल्कुल इग्नोर कर
देंगे राइट बिल्कुल ही इग्नोर मार देंगे
एंड मैं यहां पे शमीम को मॉडरेटर बना देता
हूं ताकि अगर कोई ऐसा कुछ आए तो ही कैन
एक्चुअली
अ ही कैन एक्चुअली पुट द यूजेस इन टाइम
आउट तो शमीम इज नाउ अ मॉडरेटर आल्सो ताकि
हमारा डिस्टरबेंस ना हो चलिए तो यहां पे
अब हम सिंपल क्या करते हैं पहला कॉलम हमने
देखा क्या था एक एचटीटीपी मेथड दूसरा जो
था रिक्वेस्टेड यूल जो मैंने आपको बताया
तीसरा जो था एचटीटीपी वर्जन के बारे में
बताता है कौन सा एचटीटीपी वर्जन यहां पे
यूज हो रहा है ठीक है तो यहां पे 1.1 1.1
ये 1.0 1.1 ये सारे वर्जंस है तो तो 1.1
मोस्ट ऑफ द ब्राउजर्स जो है यूज करते हैं
ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे कुछ कॉमन
रिक्वेस्ट की बात करते हैं यहां पे कुछ
कॉमन यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट की यहां पे आपको
देखते हैं जैसे कि आप रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स की
देखते हैं जैसे कि एक रेफरर हेडर होता है
इसके बारे में भी हम पढ़ेंगे यूजर एजेंट
हेडर होता है होस्ट हेडर होता है कुकी ये
कुछ कॉमन हेडर्स हैं ठीक है उसके बाद यहां
पे एक एचटीटीपी रिस्पांस टैब है जो कुछ इस
तरीके से दिखता है तो पहले हमने क्या देखा
पहले हमने पहले एटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट देखा कि
कुछ रिक्वेस्ट में इस तरीके की चीज होती
है ये पहला जो लाइन है इस तरीके से पहले
लाइन में तीन कॉलम जो है वो एचटीटीपी मेथड
यूआरएल एंड एटीटीपी वर्जन दिखाता है बाकी
सारे रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स आपको देखने को मिल
जाते हैं उसी तरीके से एचटीटीपी रिस्पांस
आपको कुछ इस तरीके से देखने को मिल जाता
है एंड इसमें भी आपको कुछ चीजें देखने को
मिल जाती है पहले लाइन के अंदर में तो
पहले लाइन के अंदर में क्या होता है सबसे
पहला जो होता है एटीटीपी वर्जन बीइंग
यूज्ड तो यहां पे हमारा एचटीटी वर्जन है
1.1 सिंपल ये वर्जन यूज हो रहा है उसके
बाद क्या अ न्यूमेरिक स्टेटस कोड
इंडिकेटिंग द रिजल्ट ऑफ द रिक्वेस्ट जो
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी गई थी ना क्लाइंट के साइड
से जो पाथ को एक्सेस करने के लिए
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी गई थी उस पाथ को एक्सेस कर
पाए नहीं कर पाए क्या प्रॉब्लम हुई एरर आई
एरर आई तो कैसी एरर आई वह आपको एरर कोड
यानी कि स्टेटस कोड यहां पर दिख जाता है
जो कि 200 यहां पर आपको दिख रहा है इसका
मतलब होता है
सक्सेसफुल तीसरा होता है अ टेक्चुअल रीजन
फ्रेज फरदर डिस्क्राइबिंग द स्टेटस ऑफ द
रिस्पांस यानी कि 200 एंड दिस इज ओके डन
ओके है भाई कोई दिक्कत नहीं यह होता है
हमारा क्या एसटीडीपी रिस्पांस का पहला जो
रो है उनके जो कॉलम्स है उनकी जानकारी ठीक
है तो यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया एंड कुछ
कॉमन रिस्पांस हेडर्स जो आपको है देखने को
मिलेंगे वो है सर्वर सेट कुकी प्रग्मा
कंटेंट टाइप कंटेंट लेंथ ठीक है तो हमने
अभी-अभी क्या-क्या देखा हमने
देखा एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट कैसा दिखता है
पहले लाइन में क्या-क्या चीजें हैं और
उसके उसके बाद रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स हैं उसके
बाद हमने कुछ कॉमन एटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स के बारे में देखा यहां पे देखा
कौन-कौन से रेफरर यूजर एजेंट होस्ट कुकी
उसके बाद हमने एटीटीपी रिस्पांस कैसा
दिखता है वो देखा पहले लाइन में जो कॉलम्स
है वो क्या-क्या है वो हमने देखा एंड उसके
बाद हमने कुछ कॉमन रिस्पांस हेडर्स देखा
सर्वर सेट कुकी प्रग्मा कंटेंट टाइप
कंटेंट लेंथ ये सारी चीजें अब इन सब को हम
डिटेल में भी जानेंगे एंड डिटेल में भी
सीखेंगे ठीक है हम डिटेल में भी
समझेंगे ओके अब चलो डिटेल में चलने से
पहले एक कोई कमेंट है वो देख लेते हैं अ
थैंक यू फुल सपोर्ट लव यू लव यू टू गाइज
लव यू टू एंड थैंक यू वेरी
मच आप इतना डीप पढ़ाते हैं इसकी वजह से
आपसे पढ़ते हैं सर वरना
फ्री में ऐसी क्वालिटी कंटेंट इतना डीप
कंटेंट देना कि आपको ऐसा ना फील हो कि यह
बंदा फ्री में कुछ भी डाल के जा रहा है
मतलब कुछ भी दे रहा है क्या कि फ्री का
कंटेंट है पेड कंटेंट टाइप लगना चाहिए वो
मोटिव है तो यहां पे सर मैं एक बात कहना
चाहूंगा मैं बहुत से कोर्स एंड मेथड को
देख खुद की मेथड बनाने के लिए लाइक जेसन
हैडिंग एंड मेनी लाइट हंटर्स दे ऑल आर गुड
बट द वे यू टीच इट इज इनक्रेडिबल मैं आपको
बहुत पहले से फॉलो कर रहा हूं क्या कौन
जैसे ही मैंने लैपटॉप लिया सीखने के लिए
आपने कोर्स लच कर दिया ग्रेट सैल्यूट टू
सर मैं फेक नहीं रहा हूं सच में बहुत कुछ
लिखना है बट बस आप फीलिंग को समझिए राइट
साइबर रॉकी आई कैन अंडरस्टैंड योर फीलिंग
एंड थैंक यू सो मच फॉर योर लवली वर्ड्स
दीज वर्ड्स मींस अ लॉट टू अस यह वर्ड्स के
कारण ही इतना कंटेंट 20 लेक्चर आ चुके एक
लेक्चर का एवरेज ड्यूरेशन दो घंटे का है
40 घंटे का भाई इतने तो पेड कोर्स में भी
इतने घंटे के कोर्स नहीं होते 40 घंटे की
मैं सच बता रहा हूं एंड हमने वो डिलीवर
यहां पर किया है वी आर सक्सेसफुली वी हैव
डिलीवर्ड एंड वी आर प्राउड ऑन इट और ऐसे
40 घंटे और अभी आने वाले हैं मतलब अभी और
आएंगे भाई मेरा अप्रॉक्स मिनिमम 100 आवर्स
का यह बनाने का है टोटल बट अगर 100 आवर्स
से ज्यादा हो गए तो वो भी चलेगा वो भी
आएगा अगर अगर हो गया तो अच्छी बात है बट
मुझे नहीं लगता 100 आर्स में कंप्लीट
होंगे तो और भी आएंगे
राइट थैंक यू सर हम पाकिस्तान से आपको देख
रहे हैं मिस्टर एरर थैंक यू सो
मच कुछ लोगों को कल गई काल गई है सर यस यस
यस थैंक यू चलो बढ़िया अब ये तो हमने देखा
अब हमने एसटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्पांस
हेडर उसके बारे में बहुत डिटेल में हम
जानने वाले हैं ठीक है ये ये पूरा मैंने
आपके लिए ये चीज रखी हुई है ये पूरी डिटेल
में हम जानेंगे बट उसके पहले अब हम समझते
हैं एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के बारे में यह कौन
सा मेथड जो है वो मेथड वही है जो आपको
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट जो होती है उसमें सबसे
पहला कॉलम आपको देखने को मिल जाता है यह
मेथड आप इसमें भी बब शूट के अंदर भी
देखेंगे यहां पे जब मैं चलता हूं रिपीटर
के ऊपर में तो आपको यहां दिख रहा होगा यह
पहला रिक्वेस्ट में मेथड यह मेथड के बिना
कोई भी रिक्वेस्ट अधूरी है एंड दिस इज द
मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग चलिए तो मेथड के
बारे में समझते हैं क्या होता है भैया
एचटीटीपी मेथड तो एचटीटीपी मेथड्स जो है
बेसिकली यूज में आते हैं जब आप व्हेन यू
आर अटैकिंग वेब एप्लीकेशन यू विल बी
डीलिंग ऑलमोस्ट एक्सक्लूसिवली विद द मोस्ट
कॉमनली यूज मेथड्स गेट एंड पोस्ट यू नीड
टू बी अवेयर ऑफ सम इंपोर्टेंट डिफरेंसेस
बिटवीन दज मेथड्स दे कैन अफेक्ट एन
एप्लीकेशन सिक्योरिटी इफ ओवरलुक्ड
स ओवरलुक्ड कुछ ज्यादा आपने ध्यान दे दिया
तो वेब एप्लीकेशन की सिक्योरिटी
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो सकती है भैया लिटरली
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो सकती
है ठीक
है थैंक यू थारा भाई जोगिंदर थैंक यू तुम
तो बहुत यार रेगुलर रहते हो मैंने दे देखा
है तुम्हारा नाम मेरे को याद ही हो गया है
बहुत लोग जो रेगुलर होते हैं उनका नाम
मुझे याद हो गया
है सो थैंक
यू
बाउंटीफुल बिल्कुल आना बिल्कुल आना भाई यू
विल बी प्रो बाय द एंड ऑफ 2024 स्ट्रिक्ट
टू लाइव या या करेक्ट एब्सलूट करेक्ट
चलिए तो यहां पे अब आते हैं समझते हैं कि
ये जो मेथड्स है ये क्या है सबसे पहले जो
मोस्ट कॉमन मेथड है उसको देखते हैं गेट
एंड पोस्ट जो आपको सिंपल यहां पर देखने को
मिल जाता है रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर में जो
एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट होती है उसके अंदर में
यहां प आपको देखने को मिल जाता है जब आप
ये सब जान जाएंगे तो मजा आएगा यार द गेट
मेथड यूज टू य इज डिजाइंड टू या यूज टू
रिट्रीव रिसोर्सेस जो रिसोर्सेस आपको
चाहिए उसको रिड्राफ्ट
तो तुम गेट मेथड का यूज करोगे एंड उस थाली
को
रिट्रेस है सर्वर प व एड्रेस डाल दोगे एंड
रिक्वेस्ट करोगे वो थाली आपको मिल जाएगी
अगर वहां सर्वर पे है सर्वर पर नहीं है तो
आपको वही एक एरर मिल जाती है जब सर्वर पर
कोई चीज रिक्वेस्ट करो एंड वह आपको वहां
पर अवेलेबल नहीं होती है एंड वो आप
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हो तो आपको एक एरर मिलती
है भैया एंड इस एरर के बारे में आप सबको
पहले से पता है
404 नॉट फाउंड अगर वो सर्वर पे अवेलेबल
एक्चुअल में नहीं है किसी तरह का
रिस्ट्रिक्शन वगैरह है ये सब है तब तो अलग
आपको रिस्ट्रिक्शन वाले फर 4x वाले एरर
मिलेंगे बट अगर बिल्कुल नहीं है तो आपको
404 नॉट फाउंड का एरर मिलेगा ठीक है
चलिए अब देखो यहां
पे इट कैन बी यूज टू सेंड पैरामीटर्स टू द
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स इन द यूआरएल क्वेरी
स्ट्रिंग पैरामीटर्स को सेंड करने के लिए
भी यूज किया जाता है पैरामीटर्स को कैसे
सेंड करने के लिए किया जाता है जैसे आपका
यहां पर मैं चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड करता हूं
यहां पे तो यहां
पे मैं टारगेट पर चलता हूं जैसे मैंने
यहां पे पैरम वाले कोई एक रिक्वेस्ट है
उसको ले लेते हैं पैरामीटर ये शायद नहीं
हुआ है तो मैं इसको स्कैन कर देता हूं
स्पाइडर कर देता हूं ताकि स्पाइडरिंग
स्टार्ट हो जाएगी तो हमें कुछ पैरामीटर
वाले यहां पर मिल जाएंगे ताकि हमें पता चल
जाए ताकि हम देख पाए यहां प जैसे हमें ओके
200 स्टस पैरामीटर्स ले लेते
हैं यस वी गट इट हियर तो यहां पर आपका एक
पैरामीटर आया है ठीक है यह वर्जन
है या इसको सेंड टू रिपीटर में कर देता
हूं यहां पर रिपीटर प चलते हैं अब गेट का
यूज आप यहां पर क्या लिखा हुआ है सिंपल सा
यहां पर क्या मेंशन है यहां पर इट कैन बी
यूज टू सेंड पैरामीटर्स टू द रिक्वेस्ट
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स इन द यूआरएल क्वेरी
स्ट्रिंग तो यूआरएल का जो क्वेरी स्ट्रिंग
है जैसे आपका ये यूआरएल क्वेरी स्ट्रिंग
है तो यहां पर आपका एक पैरामीटर ऐड किया
जा सकता सकता है गेट के थ्रू तो यहां पे
जो पैरामीटर है आपका यहां पे s पैरामीटर
यहां पे दिया हुआ है जिसके अंदर एक कोई
वैल्यू यहां पे असाइन हो जाती है वैल्यू
आप यहां पे सर्च करेंगे तो वो वैल्यू यहां
पे आ जाती है तो यहां पे ये पैरामीटर के
लिए भी पैरामीटर असाइनमेंट के लिए भी यूज़
में किया जाता है दिस इनेबल्स यूजर्स टू
बुकमार्क अ यूआरएल फॉर अ डायनेमिक रिसोर्स
दैट दे कैन रीयूज मतलब इसी के कारण से आप
कोई भी यूआरएल को बुकमार्क कर लेते हैं
जैसे ये यूआरएल है बुकमार्क करना है तो
आपने यहां पे बुकमार्क कर लिया एंड इसको
वापस से बाद में कभी मान लो आपने इस को
क्लोज कर दिया तो बाद में आप बुकमार्क
वाले पे क्लिक करोगे तो ये उसी पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को रिक्वेस्ट करेगा उसी
पर्टिकुलर सर्वर को एंड आपके सामने पेज जो
है वो सामने आ जाएगी एंड गेट मेथड का यूज
कर लेगा ठीक है और अदर यूजर्स कैन
रिट्रांसलेशन स्क्रीन एंड आर लॉग इन
वेरियस प्लेसेस सच एज ब्राउजर हिस्ट्री
एंड द वेब सर्वर्स एक्सेस लॉ तो यूआरएल के
बारे में आप सबको यह तो पता ही है सिंपल
सा कि कहीं बहुत जगह पे लॉक्ड हो जाती है
एंड कहीं से भी आप इसको एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं ठीक है दे आर आल्सो ट्रांसमिटेड इन द
रेफरर हेडर टू द टू अदर साइट्स व्हेन
एक्सटर्नल लिंक्स आर फॉलो अब यूआरएल जो है
रेफरल हेडर में भी आते हैं जैसे आपको यहां
पे दिख रहा होगा कि मैंने यहां पे गेट
वाली क्वेरी यहां पे करी यहां पे गेट वाली
अ जो रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे तो आपको यहां
पे एक रेफरल हेडर मिल रहा होगा जो कि आपको
एक अलग पेज पे लेकर जाता
है सिंपल तो यही वो चीज है रेफरल हेडर
जहां पे आपको यूआरएल मिल जाते हैं इस इस
जगह पे भी आपको यूआरएल मिल जाता है रेफरर
हेडर राइट बस
दैट्ची जाती है हां गेट मेथड में एक बहुत
जरूरी चीज है फॉर दीज रीजंस यहां
देखो फॉर दीज रीजंस द क्वेरी स्ट्रिंग शुड
नॉट बी यूज्ड टू ट्रांसमिट एनी इनफ
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन जब गेट का यूज़ होता
है तो यूआरएल के अंदर में ना कोई भी
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन ट्रांसफर नहीं होनी
चाहिए कोई एपीआई की नहीं होनी चाहिए किसी
तरह का कोई पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स जो किसी
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड एरिया को एक्सेस करने के
लिए बनाया गया है वह कोई पाथ है उसका वहां
पे यूज़ नहीं होना चाहिए क्योंकि वहां पे
वह डायरेक्टली प्लेन आपको दिखेगा कई सारे
यूआरएल जो हैं वह इनकोडेड आते हैं कई सारे
यूआरएल आपको इनकोडेड मिलेंगे जैसे यह
रैपिड का है मान लो यहां पे मैं किसी एक
पर्टिकुलर पेज पर जाता हूं यहां पर यह पेज
पर मैं गया य पर इस पेज पर अब इस पेज पर
गया तो यह पूरी की पूरी यूआरएल आ रही है
यह पूरी की पूरी यूआरएल अब इस यूआरएल में
कोई ऐसी कोई सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
होनी
चाहिए जो यहां पर रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही अदर
वाइज दे कैन बी ट्राइव एंड वह
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो सकता है वह एक सिक्योरिटी
इशू हो सकते हैं क्योंकि वहां पर व
डायरेक्टली दिख जाएगा यल स्ट्रंग ठीक है
अब पोस्ट मेथड क्या होता है पोस्ट मेथड इ
डिजाइंड ठीक है प मेथड डिजाइन टू परफॉर्म
एक्शन एक्शन परफॉर्म करना है त पोस्ट मेथड
यूज करो विद दिस मेथड रिक्वेस्ट
पैरामीटर्स कैन बी सेंट बोथ इन यूआरएल
कोरी स्ट्रिंग्स एंड इन द बॉडी ऑफ द मैसेज
अब इसमें क्या चेंज आया कि पोस्ट मेथड का
जब यूज करोगे तो रिक्वेस्ट पैरामीटर जो
होते हैं ना व यूआरएल में तो भेज सकते हो
साथ में तुम मैसेज के बॉडी में भी
पैरामीटर्स भेज सकते हो सिंपल सा फंड है
जैसे इसके बाद कोई मैसेज बॉडी आती है यहां
पे मैसेज बॉडी कोई होता है तो इस
पर्टिकुलर मैसेज जैसे कि मैं यहां पे एक
डालता हूं य नेम इ इक्वल टू
रूट
एंड य नेम इक्वल टू रूट पासवर्ड या पास
डब्डीसैक्स
हैं आप पैरामीटर्स ऐड अप कर सकते हैं ये
पोस्ट मेथड का कमाल
लद द यूआरएल कैन स्टिल बी बुक मार्क्ड एनी
पैरामीटर सेंट इन द मैसेज बॉडी विल बी
एक्सक्लूडेड फ्रॉम बुकमार्क समझ में आया
यह एक सिक्योरिटी रीजंस आप बोल सकते हैं
सिक्योरिटी रीजंस की वजह से यह काफी अच्छा
भी है कि मैसेज बॉडी में कुछ अगर सेंसिटिव
भी है मान लो और तुमने बुकमार्क कर लिया
पोस्ट वाली पोस्ट मेथड का यूज़ करने वाली
यूआरएल को तो इसका मतलब यह नहीं कि तुम वो
कोई और एक्सेस करेगा तो तुम्हें वो वाली
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाएगी मैसेज बॉडी
से जैसे यहां पे यूजर नेम और जैसे यहां पे
यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड है तो इसका मतलब ये
नहीं कि वो तुम्हें मिल जाएगी नहीं
बुकमार्क सिर्फ और सिर्फ वही होगा जो नॉट
सेंसिटिव
है दैट्ची
है यानी कि पैरामीटर्स जो है मैसेज बॉडी
में वो एक्सक्लूड कर दिए जाते हैं दिस
पैरामीटर्स विल आल्सो बी एक्सक्लूडेड
फ्रॉम वेरियस लोकेशंस इन व्हिच लॉग्स ऑफ
यूआरएल आर मेंटेन फ्रॉम द रेफरल हेडर वही
सेम चीज है रेफरल हेडर वाले भी लॉग से भी
हटा दिए जाते हैं एज सिंपल ए ठीक है प्लीज
डोंट स्पैम अर्निंग अर्निंग आई लव यू सर
आपसे मैंने बहुत कुछ सीखा है अभी तक और
पूरी थैंक यू थैंक यू सो मच बट प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम
राइट चलिए तो यह आपको समझ में आ गया अब
यहां पे देखो यहां पे यहां पे बिकॉज द
पोस्ट मेथड इज डिजाइंड फॉर परफॉर्मिंग
एक्शन इफ अ यूजर क्लिक्स ब्राउजर्स बैक
बटन टू रिटर्न टू अ पेज दैट वाज एक्सेस्ड
यूजिंग दिस मेथड द ब्राउजर डज नॉट
ऑटोमेटिक री इशू द
रिक्वेस्ट इसका मतलब समझ में आ रहा है
आपको क्या हो रहा है यह चीज आप सब ने कहीं
पर नोटिस करा है क्या कि बैक बैक बटन
दबाने पर आप प्रीवियस पेज पर जा ही नहीं
रहे हो ऐसा किसी ने नोटिस करा और कहां
नोटिस करा बताइए देखते हैं कितने लोगों ने
नोटिस करा बताइए मुझे आप लोग में से कितने
लोगों ने नोटिस करा कोई ऐसी वेबसाइट खोली
हो जनरली हर लोग ऐसी वेबसाइट खोलते हैं यह
वेबसाइट और बैक बटन दबाने पर क्या होता है
प्रीवियस पेज पर नहीं जाता या तो यूजर
टाइम आउट हो जाता है या सेशन एक्सपायर हो
जाता है कुछ इस तरीके की चीजें परफॉर्म हो
जाती है
बताइए लेट मी
नो य आकाश मिश्रा इ से ट्रांजैक्शन पेज
बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल एब्सलूट करेक्ट फ में
ऐसा नहीं होता फ में तो बैक हो जाओगे
आप क्रिप्टो में आए मेरे सा ठीक है मोस्ट
ऑफ द टाइम न बैंक वेबसाइट एब्सलूट करेक्ट
ट्रांजेक्शन वेब यस मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम
बैंक्स की वेबसाइट जो है उस परे आपको यह
चीज देखने को मिल जाता है जब भी आप बैंक
वेबसाइट पे जाते हो तो देखो जैसे मैं क्या
करता हूं मैं ऑनलाइन एसबीआई इस बैंक पे
चलते
हैं मैंने इसको ओपन
किया ठीक है अब देखो मैं यहां पे ना मान
लो किसी पेज पे चलता हूं मान लो लेट्स
सपोज किसी पेज पे चलता हूं जैसे कि मैं
क्या क्या डोनेशन वाली ये तो कोई और
वेबसाइट ओपन हो गई कलेक्ट इस पे चल जाते
हैं ठीक है एसबीआई कलेक्ट मैं यहां पे आ
चुका ए कलेक्ट अब मैं अगर यहां पर बैक बटन
प्रेस करूंगा ना यहां पे तो वापस से मैं
बैक हो जाऊंगा क्योंकि हम ऑथेंटिकेटेड
यूजर नहीं है वी आर नॉट ऑथेंटिकेटेड राइट
नाउ हम अनऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर है तो उस केस
में बैक होगा बट जैसे ही आप ऑथेंटिकेटेड
हो जाओगे एंड जब आप बैक बटन प्रेस करोगे
वहां पे तो वहां पे यही चीज परफॉर्म होगी
वह क्या है कि पोस्ट मेथड इज रिजाइन र
परफॉर्मिंग एक्शंस इफ अ यूजर क्लिक द
ब्राउजर्स बैक बटन टू रिटर्न टू अ पेज दैट
वाज एक्सेस्ड यूजिंग दिस मेथड द ब्राउजर
डज नॉट ऑटोमेटिक रिइश्यू द
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है क्योंकि यहां पे हो सकता
है गेट मेथड यूज हो रहा हो जो अभी हमने
यहां पे एक्सेस करने की कोशिश की बट जब आप
पोस्ट में आप ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर की तरह जब
आप एक्सेस कर रहे होते हो वहां पे कुछ ऐसी
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज सेट कर दी जाती हैं
मोस्ट ऑफ द बैंक वेबसाइट्स के तरफ से कि
जैसे ही आप बैक बटन प्रेस करते हो इट विल
डिटेक्ट एंड क्योंकि ब्राउजर ऑटोमेटिक
रिइश्यू नहीं करेगा
उस रिक्वेस्ट को तो जिस तरीके से वेब
सर्वर ट्राई चाहेगा उसको एक्सेस करवाना उस
तरीके से करवाएगा एंड वहां एक सिक्योरिटी
मैकेनिज्म यह होगी कि आप जैसे ही बैक करते
हो यूजर का सेशन जो है इनवैलिडेट हो जाता
है टर्मिनेट हो जाता है एंड वहां पर आपको
वो एक्सेस का नहीं एक्सेस कर पाते हैं
वहां पर सेशन एक्सपायर्स जैसा कुछ मैसेज आ
जाता
है ठीक
है गॉट
इट
यस करेक्ट एब्सलूट करेक्ट नॉट एलस बिल्कुल
मोस्टली हम देखते हैं लॉगइन में बट हम
जनरल में भी पोस्ट मेथड का पोस्ट मेथड का
यूज़ देख सकते हैं जरूरी नहीं है लॉगइन
टाइम ही देखें जनरल क्वेरीज भी पोस्ट मेथड
से हो सकती है जब सर्वर से कोई इंटरेक्शन
हो रही हो किसी तरह का ऑथेंटिकेटेड
इंटरेक्शन हो रहा है उस केस में हम पोस्ट
मेथड का यूज़ कर सकते हैं या देखा जा सकता
है इस मेथड का यूज़ होते हुए ठीक है अब
देखो यहां पे इंस्टेड इंस्टेड इट वांट्स द
यूजर ऑफ व्ट इट इज अबाउट टू डू दिस
प्रिवेंट यूजर्स फ्रॉम अनविटिंग
परफॉर्मिंग एन एक्शन मोर देन वंस एक बार
से ज्यादा ना हो यह होता है इससे फॉर दिस
रीजन पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट शुड ऑलवेज बी यूज वन
एन एक्शन इज बीइंग परफॉर्म इसलिए एक्शन जब
परफॉर्म हो तो पोस्ट मेथड का यूज किया
जाता है ऐसे सर मैं इलेक्शन में हूं बट
मुझे आपका सेक्शन बहुत अच्छा लगता है
ग्रेट पटेल
ग्रेट ग्रेट थैंक यू बहुत बढ़िया चलिए
चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं इन एडिशन टू गेट
एंड पोस्ट मेथड द एसटीडीपी प्रोटोकॉल
सपोर्ट्स न्यूमरस अदर मेथड्स बहुत सारे और
मेथड्स है जैसे कि हेड है ट्रेस है ऑप्शंस
है पुट है यह सारे मेथड्स ये सपोर्ट करता
है जैसे हेड मेथड है तो फंक्शन इन द सेम
वे एज अ गेट मेथड एक्सेप्ट दैट द सर्वर
शुड नॉट रिटर्न अ मैसेज बॉडी इन इट्स
रिस्पांस इस अगर आप हेड का यूज कर रहे हैं
या हेड यूज हो रहा है मतलब बेसिकली तो
उसका मतलब यह है कि ये गेट की तरह ही यूज
होता है बट
सर्वर जो है ना मैसेज
बॉडी रिटर्न नहीं करना चाहिए इसके केस में
द सर्वर शुड रिटर्न द सेम हेडर्स दैट इट
वुड हैव रिटर्न टू द करेस्पॉन्डिंग्ली
अ मेकिंग अ गेट रिक्वेस्ट मतलब इसका यूज
करके यह चेक किया जा सकता है कि कोई
पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स सर्वर पे है कि नहीं है
हेड का यूज करके अगर है तो फिर आगे फरदर
गेट रिक्वेस्ट कीजिए एंड फिर अपना जो काम
करना है कीजिए क्योंकि आपको पता चल चुका
है तो दिस इ हेड मेथड उसके बाद है ट्रेस
इट इ डिजाइंड फॉर डायग्नोस्टिक पर्पस
ट्रेस से आपको समझ में आ रहा है द सर्वर
शुड रिटर्न इन द रिस्पांस बॉडी द एक्ट
कंटेंट ऑफ द रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज इट
रिसी ट्रेस का यूज होता
है एंड तब सर्वर जो है रेस्प बॉडी में
एग्जैक्ट वही कंटेंट जो है
ना रिटर्न करता है जो रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज के
थ्रू गया था उसके पास जो रिक्वेस्ट की गई
थी जो भी रिक्वेस्ट उसने रिसीव की थी उसका
एग्जैक्ट कंटेंट वो रिस्पांस के तौर पर
सेंड करता है दिस कैन बी यूज टू डिटेक्ट द
इफेक्ट ऑफ एनी प्रॉक्सी सर्वस बिटवीन द
क्लाइंट एंड द सर्वर दैट मे मैनिपुलेट द
रिक्वेस्ट इससे पता चल जाएगा अगर मान लो
मैंने कुछ रिक्वेस्ट करा ठीक है कोई
पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स अगर सेम
एग्जैक्ट कंटेंट मुझे नहीं मिल रहा है
रिटर्न में मैसेज बॉडी में रिस्पांस बॉडी
में इसका मतलब कुछ ना कुछ वहां पर बीच में
प्रॉब्लम है दिक्कत है बीच में किसी ना
किसी तरह की चीज है वहां एजिस्ट करती है
जो कि एक प्रॉक्सी सर्वर हो सकता है तो
इसके लिए भी यूज मिल लिया जाता है उसके
बाद है ऑप्शंस आस्क द सर्वर टू रिपोर्ट द
एसटीटीपी मेथड्स दैट आर अवेलेबल फॉर अ
पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स ऑप्शंस का यूज करके यह
पता चलता
है कि कौन-कौन से एचटीटीपी मेथड्स
वो अलाउड है या अवेलेबल है उस पर्टिकुलर
रिसोर्स के लिए अब बहुत सारे सर्वर्स पुट
एचटीटीपी मेथड को पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स के
लिए बंद करके रखते हैं बैन करके रखते हैं
यू कैन नॉट यूज पुट मेथड क्योंकि बहुत ही
ज्यादा हाईली अ लाइक वल्नरेबल मेथड है एक
तरह का जिसका थोड़ा भी मिस कॉन्फिन बहुत
क्रिटिकल अ अपलोड वनबिल को एग्जीक्यूट कर
सकती है या फाइल अपलोड वनबिल को
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकती है सो दिस इज दिस इज
पुट एंड इन सारे जो एसटीडीपी मेथड्स है
हेड ट्रेस या ऑप्शन से पुट जो भी है कौन
सा अवेलेबल है उसके बारे में ऑप्शन से पता
लगाया जा सकता है एज सिंपल एजट यह इसका
वही काम है बेचारे का द सर्वर टिपिकली
रिटर्न्स अ रिस्पांस कंटेनिंग एन अलाउ
हेडर दैट लिस्ट्स द अवेलेबल मेथड्स एक
अलाउ हेडर आता है जिसमें कि सारे जो
अवेलेबल मेथड्स है वह बता देता है अब इनका
काम यह खुद ही बेचारे कर देते हैं बता भी
देते हैं पुट यह बहुत ही खतरनाक एचटीटीपी
मेथड है अटेम्प्ट्स टू अपलोड द स्पेसिफाइड
रिसोर्स टू द सर्वर इसका यूज करके कोई एक
स्पेसिफिक रिसोर्स सर्वर पे अपलोड करने के
लिए यूज में लिया जाता है यूजिंग द कंटेंट
कंटेंड इन द बॉडी ऑफ द रिक्वेस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी के कंटेंट के अकॉर्डिंग इफ
दिस मेथड इज इनेबल्ड यू मे बी एबल टू
लिवरेज इट टू अटैक द एप्लीकेशन सच एज बाय
अपलोडिंग एन आर्बिट्री स्क्रिप्ट एंड
एग्जीक्यूटिंग ऑन द सर्वर जैसे कि मैंने
आपको बताया यहां पे कोई एक मेलिश अस हैकर
जो है ना पुट का यूज करके अगर ये अलाउड है
ऑप्शन से चेक कर सकते हैं अगर ये अलाउड है
बाय चांस तो पुट का यूज करके कोई अटैकर
अपनी शेल या कोई मलिस स्क्रिप्ट उस
पर्टिकुलर सर्वर पे अपलोड कर सकता है उस
पाथ प एंड ट्स इट सेल अपलोड कर दिया आपने
सेल कर दिया वेबसाइट को अब वेबसाइट को आप
कंट्रोल कर लो वही डिफेस कर लो या जो करना
है कर लो जो करते
हैं दिस इट तो यह एटीटीपी मेथड्स के बारे
में हमने बात कर हमें डीपी मेथड के बारे
में बहुत ज्यादा डीप नहीं जाना था बट
स्टिल हमने बहुत कुछ देखा मैंने सोचा आपको
बताना चाहिए कांसेप्ट बहुत जरूरी है तो
बताया अब आ जाते हैं एचटीटीपी हेडर्स में
एंड इसमें आते हैं जनरल हेडर्स रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स एंड रिस्पांस हेडर के बारे में
समझते
हैं ठीक है तो आपको ये सारे यहां पे दिख
रहा होगा अब आपको थोड़ा समझ में आ जाएगा
तो एसटीडीपी हेडर्स के बारे में समझते
हैं अ व्हाट इज
दिस
ओके क्या बोल रहे
हो गेट यस ठीक
है यस करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट बिल्कुल सही
ट्रेस मेथड इज लाइक सेंडिंग अ लेटर टू अ
कार्बन कॉपी टू योरसेल्फ व्हेन यू सेंड अ
लेटर यू आल्सो गेट अ कॉपी एवरीथिंग रिटेन
इन द लेटर सिमिलरली व्हेन यू यूज द ट्रेस
मेथ बिल्कुल एब्सलूट करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट
इट शोज यू द स्टेप्स यूरिक टेक टू इट शोज
यू द स्टेप्स यू योर रिक्वेस्ट टेक एज इट
ट्रेवल्स थ्रू द डिफरेंट सर्वर्स इट
हेल्प्स इन अंडरस्टैंडिंग हाउ अ रिक्वेस्ट
इज हैंडल्ड बाय डिफरेंट एब्सलूट वन मिनट
बिल्कुल सही ओके बिल्कुल सही ठीक है बहुत
अच्छा अगर आपका कांसेप्ट क्लियर है किसी
का भी कांसेप्ट क्लियर है बहुत बढ़िया
बहुत बढ़िया बट जिनका क्लियर नहीं है उस
चीज को समझिए ठीक है जो भी चीजें मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं समझिए तो ट्रेस के बारे में
ऑलरेडी वन मिनट गेमिंग लर्निंग जो है काफी
अच्छा उन्होंने बता दिया है तो आप समझ
लीजिएगा बस सिंपल सा एक इतना ही मतलब है
कि डायग्नोस्टिक पर्पस के लिए यूज में
किया जाता है ठीक है तो
सर्वर शुड रिटर्न इन द रिस्पांस बॉडी द
एजेक्ट कंटेंट ऑफ द रिक्वेस्टेड मैसेज जो
एजेक्ट कंटेंट है उसको ही रिटर्न करेगा
उससे बहुत कुछ हम डायग्नोज कर सकते हैं
ट्स इट ठीक है डायग्नोस्टिक के लिए यूज
में होता अब यहां पे हम बात करते हैं
हेडर्स के बारे में तो एसटीडीपी सपोर्ट्स
लार्ज नंबर ऑफ हेडर्स सम ऑफ चच आर डिजाइंड
फॉर स्पेसिफिक अनयूजुअल परपस सम हेडर्स
कैन बी यूज फॉर बोथ रिक्वेस्ट एंड
रिस्पांस एंड अदर्स आर स्पेसिफिक टू वन ऑफ
दिस मैसेज टाइप यानी कुछ हेडर्स
जैसे एसटीडीपी हेडर्स की जब हम बात कर रहे
थे यहां पर
यहां पर एसटीडीपी हेडर्स की बात कर रहे थे
तो यहां पर कुछ हेडर्स जो है ना कुछ
हेडर्स वो
रिक्वेस्ट एंड
रिस्पांस दोनों में ही होते हैं इन दोनों
में होते हैं कुछ हेडर्स
एंड कुछ हेडर्स स्पेसिफिकली रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स होते हैं रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर होते
हैं कुछ हेडर्स स्पेसिफिकली रिस्पांस के
अंदर होते है ठीक है तो चलिए अब यहां पे द
फॉलोइंग सेक्शन डिस्क्राइब द हेडर्स यू आर
लाइक टू एनकाउंटर व्हेन अटैकिंग द वेब
एप्लीकेशन अब यहां पे जो चीजें मैं बता
रहा हूं ये कुछ जनरल हेडर्स दज आर सम जनरल
हेडर्स जिसमें कि जनरलाइज है ये ये दोनों
जगह प हो सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
मतलब कि एक रिक्वेस्ट में भी हो सकते हैं
रिस्पांस में भी हो सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं कनेक्शन पहला आपको देखने को मिलर है
कनेक्शन ये क्या बताता है कनेक्शंस टेल्स
द अदर एंड ऑफ द कम्युनिकेशन वेदर इट शुड
क्लोज द टीसीपी कनेक्शन आफ्टर द एचटीटीपी
ट्रांसमिशन है कंप्लीटेड और कीप इट ओपन
फॉर फरदर
मैसेज कनेक्शन सिंपल सा ये चीज बताता है
जैसे मैं यहां पे चलता हूं एंड मैंने इसको
गो पे क्लिक किया यहां रिस्पांस आया ठीक
है अब यहां पे मुझे कनेक्शन यहां पे दिख
रहा होगा क्लोज कनेक्शन क्या है
क्लोज इसका मतलब और यहां रिस्पांस में भी
आपको यहां पे कनेक्शन दिख रहा है क्लोज
यानी रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर दोनों
में ही ये है कॉमन हेडर ठीक है तो क्लोज
का यहां पे मतलब क्या हुआ कि आप
कम्युनिकेशन को बंद कर दीजिए जब यह
कंप्लीट हो गया ए सिंपल टीसीपी थ्रीवे
हैंड चेक आपने पढ़ा होगा ठीक है आई होप सो
कि आपने पढ़ा होगा नहीं पढ़ा है तो उसकी
वीडियो शायद है आप देख लीजिएगा एंड उसमें
आपको पता ही होगा कि जब कोई कम्युनिकेशन
कंप्लीट हो जाती है तो वहां पर वो
टर्मिनेट कर दिया जाता है वह
कम्युनिकेशन राइट तो सेम चीज यहां पे
कनेक्शन आपका हेडर बताता है कि अदर एंड ऑफ
कम्युनिकेशन को दूसरे साइड के कम अगर
रिक्वेस्ट अगर वो रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के अंदर
में है तो रिस्पांस वाले क यानी सर्वर को
बता रहा होता है सर्वर के साइड से तो
क्लाइंट को बता रहा होता है कि भैया अगर
कम्युनिकेशन हो चुकी है हमारी बातचीत खत्म
हो चुकी है तो अब रोक दिया जाए अब इसको
क्लोज कर दिया जाए तो बस को क्लोज कनेक्शन
इज क्लोज जनरली आपको क्लोज ही मिलेगा ओपन
नहीं मिलेगा ठीक है या फिर फर्द ओपन रखना
है भाई आगे के मैसेजेस के लिए ये भी हो
सकता है डिपेंड्स टोटली डिपेंड्स राइट
चलिए
अब कंटेंट
इनकोडिंग स्पेसिफाई व्ट काइंड ऑफ इनकोडिंग
इज बीइंग यूज फॉर द कंटेंट कंटेंट इन द
मैसेज बॉडी मैसेज बॉडी में कोई कंटेंट है
जैसे कि अगर यहां है तो दिख जाएगा नहीं
होगा तो कोई बात
नहीं हेयर वी आर नॉट सीइंग हियर कुछ नहीं
यहां पे इसमें नहीं है बट कंटेंट इनकोडिंग
शायद इसमें कहीं पर दिख जाए मुझे इसमें
यहां पर दिख नहीं रहा बट ठीक है वो आपको
दिखेगा बहुत जगह पर आपको मिल जाएगा कोई
बड़ी बात वो चीज नहीं है ठीक है तो क्या
होता होता है कौन सा इनकोडिंग यूज हो रहा
है जैसे कि आपने कई जगह देखा होगा जी जिप
यूज होते हुए तो जी जिप इनकोडिंग यूज हो
रही है फॉर्मेट यूज हो रहा है पर्टिकुलर
उस कंटेंट के लिए जो मैसेज बॉडी के अंदर
में तो इनकोडिंग के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
ये देता है ठीक है जो कि यूज में बहुत सार
जीजी इनकोडिंग यूज हो जाती है बाय
एप्लीकेशंस टू कंप्रेस रिस्पांसस फॉर
फास्टर ट्रांसमिशन रिस्पांसस को कंप्रेस
करके साइज छोटा मतलब लेंथ उसका छोटा करने
के लिए ये यूज में लिया जाता है तो इसलिए
ताकि फास्टर रिस्पांस ट्रांसमिशन हो सके
तो ये कंटेंट इनकोडिंग जनरल हेडर उसके बाद
है कंटेंट लेंथ स्पेसिफाई द लेंथ ऑफ द
मैसेज बॉडी मैसेज बॉडी की लेंथ क्या होगी
इन बाइट्स बाइट्स में एक्सेप्ट इन द केस
ऑफ रिस्पांस टू हेड रिक्वेस्ट हेड
रिक्वेस्ट का जब रिस्पांस आएगा उसमें नहीं
व्हेन इट इकज द लेंथ ऑफ द बॉडी इन
रिस्पांस टू द करेस्पॉन्डिंग्ली
और कंटेंट टाइप दोनों चीजें ठीक है यहां
पे मैं आपको यहां पे देखता हूं कौन सी मिल
रही है
हमें यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ आपको दिख रहा है
जीरो है यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ बिकॉज दिस
रिस्पांस जज नो मैसेस बॉडी यहां पे मैसेज
बॉडी आपको दिख रहा है कुछ भी नहीं दिख रहा
तो यहां पे आपको जीरो ही दिखेगा राइट एकदम
से जीरो दिखेगा बट अगर मैं यहां प टारगेट
प चलता हूं मैं कोई और यहां पे जो कि
मैसेज बॉडी के साथ कोई रिक्वेस्ट है उसको
ले लेते हैं ताकि हमें थोड़ा सा पता चले
कोई मैसेज बॉडी के साथ कोई रिक्वेस्ट है
क्या लेट्स सी इफ सम रिक्वेस्ट है सम
मैसेज
बॉडी नहीं नहीं नहीं इसमें है क्या इसमें
भी नहीं है दे
नो इसमें है क्या नहीं इसमें भी मैसेज
बॉडी नहीं है कुछ
भी विदाउट पैरामीटर भी चलेगा मैसेज बॉडी
के लिए वी आर सीइंग
ओनली नथिंग
एल्स
नो नो नो नो नोनो
ननन तो यहां पर हमें तो कुछ ऐसा कुछ नहीं
मिल रहा लेकिन ठीक है हम यहां पर क्या कर
देते है ना लेट सी लेट्स
सी मैं स्कोप में चलता हूं यहां पे इसको
मैं यहां से रिमूव कर देता हूं टारगेट प
चलते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां से ये फिल्टर
भी हटा देते हैं एंड यहां पर क्या कर देता
हूं लेट्स ओपन यहां पे बब चल टेस्ट पीएपी
ववेब ठीक है ये हमने ओपन कर लिया एंड यहां
पे आई थिंक यह हमारे यहां पर आ जानी चाहिए
राइट लेटस
सी नेबल कर देते हैं लेट्स रीलोड दिस
टेस्ट
पीएचपी चलो इसको हम ड टू स्कोप कर देते
हैं स्कोप में कर देते
हैं
एंड टारगेट में चलते हैं यहां पर साइड मैप
प इन स्कोप आइटम्स करते हैं लेट्स सी इज
इट विजिबल यस य आ चुकी यहां पे एंड यहां
पर मैं क्या करता हूं कोई सा भी एक अरे
भैया हट
जाओ कोई सा भी एक यह कर लेते हैं यह रहा
यह रहा तो इसको हम करते हैं राइट क्लिक
करके सेंड टू रिपीटर रिपीटर में आ जाते
यहां पे रिपीटर प आएंगे इसको हम गो प
क्लिक करेंगे तो हमें रिस्पांस यहां पर
मिलेगा एंड यहां पे हमें रिक्वेस्ट मिल
रही है राइट
चलो तो अब तुम्हें यहां पे दिख रहा होगा
क्लियर विजिबिलिटी होगी यहां पे जिसकी बात
कर रहा था मैं कंटेंट लेंथ एंड कंटेंट
टाइप की तो कंटेंट टाइप स्पेसिफाई द टाइप
ऑफ कंटेंट कंटेंड इन द मैसेज बॉडी सच
टेक्स्ट है एचटीएमएल है या किस टाइप का
कंटेंट है वो आपको बताता है एंड कंटेंट
लेंथ जो है अगर मैसेज बॉडी में कोई कंटेंट
है उसकी लेंथ बता जैसे यहां पे मैसेज बॉडी
में यहां पे कुछ चीजें हैं कुछ कंटेंट है
तो इसका यहां पे लेंथ आपको दिख रहा होगा
19 गॉट इट यह 19 लेंथ है यहां पे अगर मैं
इसको थोड़ा कम कर दूं मान लो लाइक थोड़ा
कम कर दूं तो यहां पे कॉन्टेंट लेंथ कम हो
जाएगा एज़ सिंपल एज़ दैट तो यह बाइट्स में
आपको शो करती है कंटेंट अ अ कंटेंट यहां
पे स्पेसिफाई द लेंथ ऑफ़ द मैसेज बॉडी इन
बाट बाइट्स तो यह आपको यहां पे शो कर रही
है ठीक है उसी तरीके से कंटेंट टाइप यहां
पे आपको दिख रहा होगा यह क्या है यह
एप्लीकेशन x www4 यूआरएल इनकोड तो बेसिकली
यहां पे यह एक एप्लीकेशन है जो कि कट टाइप
में आपको दिख रहा है बस ट्स इट तो दिस आर
द जनरल हेडर्स कंटेंट लेंथ एंड कंटेंट
टाइप उसके बाद है ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
स्पेसिफाई एनी इनकोडिंग दैट वास परफॉर्म
ऑन द मैसेज बॉडी टू फैसिलिटेट इट्स
ट्रांसफर ओवर एसटीपी मैसेज बॉडी में कोई
जो कंटेंट जैसे मैसेज बॉडी में क्या है यह
वाली चीज ये एंट्री ठीक है सिंपल तो मैसेज
बॉडी के ऊपर कोई इनकोडिंग अगर यूज हो रही
है ठीक है ना ट्रांसफर करने के लिए एडीपी
के ऊप तो उसको हम बोलते हैं ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग इट इज नॉर्मली यूज टिफाई चंक
इनकोडिंग वन दिस इज एंप्लॉयड सिंपल सा फंड
है मैसेज बॉडी के ऊपर कोई इनकोडिंग है तो
उसके लिए यह ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग यूज की
जाती है कोई भी स्पेस इनकोडिंग यूज हो रही
है तो उसको स्पेसिफाई करने के लिए
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग यूज की जाती है ट्स इट
सिंपल अब यहां पे यह तो आपने जनरल हेडर्स
देख लिया हेलो हेलो दीपक आई एम गुड यर
मास्टर क्लास ऑसम थैंक यू थैंक यू मिस्टर
यूनिक
यस यस यस यू कैन
गो चलिए बहुत बढ़िया थैंक यू अब आ जाते
हैं यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स के बारे में
अब जो है रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स उनको देख लेते
हैं कि रिक्वेस्ट हेडर कौन-कौन से होते
हैं ठीक है चलिए रिक्वेस्ट सेडर में आपको
एक्सेप्ट एक्सेप्ट इनकोडिंग ऑथराइजेशन
कुकी होस्ट इफ मॉडिफाइड सेंस इन इफ नॉन
मैच ओरिजिन रेफरर यूजर एंड सब मिलेंगे एंड
ये काफी इंपोर्टेंट है याद रखिएगा तो
एक्सेप्ट क्या करता है टेल्स द सर्वर व्ट
काइंड ऑफ कंटेंट इज कंटेंट द क्लाइंट इज
विलिंग टू एक्सेप्ट सच एज इमेजेस टाइप्स
ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट फॉर्मेट एंड सो यह आपका
रिक्वेस्ट बोलता है एक्सेप्ट में तो
एक्सेप्ट में यहां पर आपको दिख रहा होगा
वाइल कार्ड कुछ भी एक्सेप्ट करेगा चलेगा
क्लाइंट को क्लाइंट सारी चीज सारी तरह के
फॉर्मेट को एक्सेप्ट करने के लिए तैयार है
दिस इ नॉट अ गुड थिंग बट स्टिल तैयार
है मतलब क्लाइंट को तो मिलना ही चाहिए ना
स के साइड से अगर आप ए अटकर देख रहे हो तो
मैं अगर क्लाइंट हूं तो मुझे सर्वर से जो
मिल रहा है ठीक है ना तो मैं लगा
दूंगा ल कार्ड सिंपल तो यह है
एक्सेप्ट उसके बाद आती है एक्सेप्ट
इनकोडिंग टेल्स द सर्वर व्ट काइंड ऑफ
कंटेंट इनकोडिंग द क्ला क्लाइंट इ विलिंग
टू एक्सेप्ट मतलब क्लाइंट कौन सी
इनकोडिंग एक्सेप्ट कर सकता है तो यहां पर
कंटेंट इनकोडिंग में आपको है कि क्लाइंट
जीप एंड डि फलेट ये दोनों इनकोडिंग जो है
वो एक्सेप्ट कर सकता है इनके बारे में
थोड़ा सा पढ़ लीजिएगा
आपको थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा मजा आ
जाएगा ठीक है दिस इज एक्सेप्ट को उसके बाद
आता है ऑथराइजेशन सबमिट्स क्रेडेंशियल टू
द सर्वर फॉर वन ऑफ द बिल्ट इन एटीटीपी
ऑथेंटिकेशन टाइप्स य ऑथराइजेशन जो है ना
यही करता है सबमिट क्रेडेंशियल को जो आप
क्रेडेंशियल डालते हो ना भैया यह
ऑथराइजेशन वाला ही सबमिट करता
है क्रेडेंशियल को
ठीक है याद रखिएगा जैसे कि मैं अगर मैं
अगर यहां
पर यहां ब शूट प यहां पर मैं चलता हूं मैं
य अगर लॉगिन प या लॉगिन वाले प चलता हूं
यहां पर ए यहां पर कोई क्रेडेंशियल डालता
हूं टेस्ट यहां पर टेस्ट ठीक है ना एंड
इसको मैं अगर इंटरसेप्ट कर लेता हूं य
प्रॉक्सी चल ग प्रॉक्सी ऑन करके एंड इफ
आईम गोइंग टू इंटरसेप्ट ट लॉगइन करता हूं
य प यहां पर तो ये इंटरसेप्ट य पर हो
जाएगा कुछ इस तरीके से यहां पर इंटरसेप्ट
हुआ ठीक है तो अब इंटरसेप्ट जो हो रहा है
तो इसमें जो यह ऑथराइजेशन वाला जो पार्ट
है जो ऑथेंटिकेशन वाला पाथ है यह
क्रेडेंशियल वाला पार्ट है यह ऑथराइजेशन
हेडर के थ्रू ही होती है ए सिंपल
ए बस इतना ही समझ लीजिए सबमिट क टू द
सर्वर सर्वर को सबमिट करता है अब जैसे
मैंने क्या किया मैं राइट क्लिक करूंगा
इसको रिपीटर को सेंड कर दूंगा एंड
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर दूंगा यहां पर ये मैं
गो पर क्लिक कर दूंगा रिस्पांस से यहां पर
200 ओके यहां पर आ जाता है
सिंपल यहां पर 200 ओके आ गया यहां पर सवर
से रिस्पांस आ गया तो यह ऑथेंटिकेशन
क्रेडेंशियल का काम सबमिट करने का जो है
आपका वह हमारे ऑथराइजेशन रिक्वेस्ट डर के
पास
है अब यहां पर आते हैं
कुकीज अब मुझे यह बताइए आप लोग पता नहीं
आप लोग में से कितने लोगों ने एक्सप्लोर
किया है क्या किया है आई डोंट नो पहले
कुकीज आता है या पहले सेट कुकी आता है यह
कुकीज पहले
हेडर जो होती है आपकी रिक्वेस्ट हेडर कुकी
कुकी यह होती है पहले यह पहले डिफाइन होता
है या पहले सेट कुकी डिफाइन होता है बताइए
मुझे एनी वन कैन
टेल
बताइए कोई बात नहीं लेट हो तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं लेट म नो एवरी
बडी पहले कुकी या सेट
कुकी
बताइए जल्दी से
बताइए पहले कुकी या सेड कुकी आईम सीइंग
एवरीवन
रेस्पों सभी लोग
बताइए कुकीज कुकीज प्रांजल से सेट कुकीज
ठीक है
सेट
कुकी सेट कुकी तो सेटस कुकी देते हैं ना
यह क्या हुआ भाई कुकी क्लाइंट साइड से और
सेट कुकी सवा साइड से होती है ठीक
है फर्स्ट कुकी देन सेट कुकी बताइए बताओ
शमीम तुम
बताओ
बताइए मोहम्मद शमीम आप
बताइए फर्स्ट फिर क्लाइंट उस कुकीज का यूज
करता है रिक्वेस्ट सेंड करता है ठीक है
डोंट नो तान्या सेट कुकीज ठीक है कुकीज
ठीक है ओके ओके काफी लोगों का आंसर आ रहा
है एंड मोस्ट ऑफ द आंसर्स हियर अ आर सेइंग
कुकीज होती है पहले एंड कुछ-कुछ लोगों ने
सेट कुकी भी बोला
है कुछ लोगों ने सेट कुकी भी बोला है राइट
चलिए मैं आपको ना यहां पे थोड़ा सा क्लियर
कर देता हूं लेट मी क्लियर दिस राइट लेट
मी क्लियर
दिस इसी को हम बोलते हैं कंसेप्ट जो आपको
समझना है जो आपको सीखना होता है ठीक है
देखो
देखो यह क्लाइंट
है एंड यह बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सर्वर
है ठीक है सर्वर दिस इ
क्लाइंट जब बात कुकीज की कर रहे होते हैं
तो सबसे
पहले सबसे पहले आपका सर्वर जो है ना यह
सेट
कुकी रिस्पांस हेडर के थ्रू सेंड करता है
रिस्पांस हेडर के थ्रू सेंड करता है इस
सेट कुकी के अंदर उसने
कुछ चीजें डिफाइन की है एंड बोला है उसी
के
डिंग रिस्पांस देने के लिए हमारे क्लाइंट
को यानी कि सर्वर कमांड करता है ऑर्डर
देता है क्लाइंट को कि भैया यह सेट कुकी
के अकॉर्डिंग ही आप एक रिप्लाई करो जो कि
होगा
कुकी बस ट्स
इट सिंपल एट राइट तो सबसे पहले नंबर पर
आपका सेट कुकी है फिर आपका कुकी
है ठीक
है
सेट कुकी पहला है एंड देन आपका कुकी आपका
और नहम सेख का पढ़ाने का तरीका सेम है
वसीम लगी अरे बाप रे तो सो यू बेसिकली
कंपेयर्ड मी टू अ लेजेंड मतलब लेजेंड
लेजेंड ऑफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन एंड
इट्स माय लाइक इट्स इट्स अ काइंड ऑफ ऑनर
टू बी कंपेयर्ड टू हिम राइट इन एनी
एस्पेक्ट इन साइबर सेक्य डोमेन तो थैंक यू
सो मच
वसीम कि नेमसेक से टू कंपेयर मी टू नेमसेक
ओके थैंक यू चलिए तो यह पहला यह दूसरा समझ
में आ रहा है ये आप समझ लीजिएगा तो अभी हम
पहले जो है वो क्या कर रहे हैं पहले हम जो
है वो हम पढ़ रहे हैं यहां पे कुकीज के
बारे में यहां पे देखिए यहां पे ऊपर जाते
हैं जो कि रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के अंदर में हम
पढ़ रहे हैं कुकीज के बारे में सबमिट्स
कुकीज टू द सर्वर दैट द सर्वर प्रीवियसली
इश्यूड देखा यहां पे भी लिखा हुआ है जो
सर्वर ने इशू किया एसेट कुकी के थ्रू उसी
को वो सबमिट करता है कुकीज वाले रिक्वेस्ट
हैडर के थ्रू बस सिंपल एज सिंपल एज दैट
उसके बाद आता है होस्ट जो कि हर जगह आपको
मिल जाएगा यह होस्ट कौन सी डोमस जो है उस
रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड कर रही है होस्ट क्या
है स्पेसिफाई द होस्ट नेम दैट अपीयर्ड इन
द फुल यूआरएल बीइंग
रिक्वेस्टेड ठीक है जो भी यूआरएल
रिक्वेस्ट हो हो रही है तो होस्ट नेम उसका
स्पेसिफाई करता है आपका होस्ट रिक्वेस्टेड
उसके बाद आता है आपका इफ मॉडिफाइड
सस स्पेसिफाई व्हेन द ब्राउजर लास्ट रिसीव
द रिक्वेस्टेड
रिसोर्स ठीक
है यह इफ मॉडिफाई सस क्या होता है
स्पेसिफाई वन द ब्राउजर लास्ट रिसीवड द
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स जो रिक्वेस्टेड
रिसोर्स
थी तो लास्ट उसको कब मिली हुई थी इफ द
रिसोर्स हैज नॉट चेंज सिंस दैट टाइम द
सर्वर मे इंस्ट्रक्ट द क्लाइंट टू यूज
इट्स कैस्ट कॉपी यूजिंग अ रिस्पांस विद द
स्टेटस कोड 304 यह समझिए यह बहुत शानदार
एक कांसेप्ट है कि इफ मॉडिफाइड सिंस यह
हेडर रिक्वेस्ट हेडर क्या बताता है कि
भैया ब्राउजर जो है ना उसको कब लास्ट
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स मिली हुई थी एंड अगर
वह रिसोर्स उसी तरीके का है अब होता क्या
है देख
लीजिए देखिए क्या होता
है यहां पर हम बात करें इफ मॉडिफाइड
ठीक है
इफ मॉडिफाइड
सिंस रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर मान लो क्लाइंट ने सर्वर से एक
रिक्वेस्ट करा
रिसोर्स रिक्वेस्ट करा
रिसोर्स ठीक है अब यह रिसोर्स यहां पर
रिसोर्स मिला
इसको ये कब मिला यह बताता है इफ मॉडिफाइड
सेंस कब मिला उसका ट्रैक है और अगर उस
टाइम से इफ
द रिक्वेस्टेड
रिसोर्स हैज नॉट बीन
चेंज्ड फ्रॉम दैट टाइम फ्रॉम दैट
टाइम अगर ये चेंज नहीं हुआ है मान लो
क्लाइंट ने एक्स वाई जड रिसोर्स को एक्सेस
करने के लिए रिक्वेस्ट किया एंड सर्वर ने
एक्स वाई जड रिस्पांस में दे दिया अब अगर
उस टाइम से यह एक्स वा जड एक्सवा जड ही है
तब से तो सर्वर तो क्या होगा उस टाइम
पर बोलेगा सर्वर क्या बोलेगा कि कैज कॉपी
यूज कीजिए क्या कीजिए कैस कॉपी इफ द
रिसोर्स ज नॉट चेंज सर्वर मे इंस्ट्रक्ट द
क्लाइंट टू यूज इट्स कैस्ट कॉपी जो
कैस्ट वर्जन उसका सेव्ड है कैश जिसको आप
बोलते हैं उसको यूज कीजिए कैश सीए सीएई
कैश मेमोरी आपने पढ़ा होगा यही कैश मेमोरी
जो ब्राउजर कैश होते है जिसको कि आप
ब्राउजर कैश भी बोलते हैं तो ब्राउजर जो
भी रिक्वेस्ट करता है जो उसको रिस्पांस
एचटीएमएल इमेजेस वगैरह वेब पेजेस मिलते
हैं उसको एक ब्राउजर के कैश में वो कलेक्ट
करके रखता है ताकि अगर वो रिसोर्स फिर से
एक्सेस करना पड़े तो डायरेक्टली कैश
मेमोरी से ही एक्सेस कर ले ब्राउजर के कैश
से बार-बार सर्वर के पास ना जाना पड़े
इससे बहुत टाइम की कपत होती है रिक्वेस्ट
में डिले होता है एंड बहुत सारा जो टाइम
है उसमें जाता है तो क्लाइंट के पास एक
यहां पे
ब्राउजर कैश मेमोरी होती है इसी में व
सारे स्टोर कर लेता है इंफॉर्मेशन को जो
भी उसने रिक्वेस्ट किया था रिस्पांस मिला
था अब अगली बार जब सेम रिक्वेस्ट के लिए
रिक्वेस्ट जब रिसोर्स के लिए रिक्वेस्ट
करना होगा तो ये क्लाइंट सीधा ब्राउजर कैश
के पास जाएगा वहीं से उठा के ले ले उसको
सर्वर के पास जाने की नीड नहीं है बिल्कुल
तो इसी इफ मॉडिफाइड सिंस के थ्रू जो कि
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में आपकी जाती है तो यह
पता चलता है कि भैया लास्ट जो रिसोर्स
एक्सेस कब हुआ था एंड वह तब से मॉडिफाइड
है कि नहीं है सर्वर के साइड से बस अब इसी
का मैं आपको एक दिखाता हूं यहां
पे नीचे थोड़ा सा आता हूं मैं रिस्पांस
वाले में यहां पर यहां पर
यहां पे यह आते हैं रिस्पांस रिस्पांस
वाले में यहां पे आपने देखा क्या इफ
मॉडिफाइड सेस ठीक है अब यहां पे एक इफ नॉन
मैच है यह भी आप देख लीजिए एंड देन हम
इसका रिस्पांस वाला जब देखेंगे तो आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा ठीक है तो व्हेन द ब्राउज
स्पेसिफाई व्हेन द ब्राउजर लास्ट रिसीव द
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स कब ब्राउजर को लास्ट
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स मिला था इफ द रिसोर्स
इज नॉट चेंज देन वो सर्वर जो है इक्ट
करेगा कि वो कैश वर्जन को यूज करें अब आते
हैं इफ नॉन मैच पे इफ नॉन मैच क्या है
स्पेसिफाई एंड एंटिटी टैग अब इफ नॉन मैच
जो है ना यह फिर से नहीं आता पहले पहले
आपका ई टैग आता है ये ई टैग जो सर्वर
रिस्पांस डर में आता है तो हम अभी समझेंगे
स्पेसिफाई एन एंटिटी टैग व्हिच इज एन
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
जैसे कुकीज वाली तरह हुआ था ना कि सेट
कुकी सर्वर इशू करता है फिर कुकीज के तरफ
से कुकीज के थ्रू रिप्लाई जाता है
रिस्पांस जाता है क्लाइंट के साइड से वैसे
ही सर्वर ई टैग जो होता है ना ई टैग
एंटिटी टैग ये वाली ई टैग इशू करता है
उसके बेसिस पर इफ नॉन मैच वाला हेडर उसको
रिप्लाई करता है सिंपल सा फंड है द
ब्राउजर सबमिट द एंटिटी टैग दैट द सर्वर
इश्यूड विथ द रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स व्हेन
इट वाज लास्ट
रिसीवड द ब्राउजर सबमिट्स द एंटिटी टैग
दैट द सर्वर
इश्यूड इशू सर्वर के द्वारा होता है विद द
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स व्हेन इट वाज लास्ट
रिसीवड कब ये लास्ट रिसीव हुआ था
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स जो है द सर्वर कैन
यूज द एंटिटी टैग टू डिटरमाइंड वेदर द
ब्राउजर मे यूज इट्स कैस्ट कॉपी ऑफ द
रिसोर्सेस अब एंटिटी टैग के
थ्रू यह बताता
है सर्वर कि
क्लाइंट कैश को उस पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स का
यूज कर सकता है या नहीं कर सकता है
एसे जिसको कि हम इफ मॉडिफाइड सेंस के थ्रू
देखते हैं एंड इफ नॉन मैच के थ्रू एक
एंटिटी टैग का जो ई टैग का रिप्लाई है वह
जाता है
एप जो कि मैसेज बॉडी के कंटेंट्स को डिनोट
करता है तोय तीनों आपस में कनेक्टेड है इफ
मॉडिफाइड सस इफ नॉन मैच एंड आपका ई टैग
याद रखिएगा
ठीक है गट
इट समझ में आ गया इतना ए सिंपल चलिए अब
आते हैं यहां पे इफ नॉन मैच भी आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा स्पेसिफाई द एंटिटी टैग जो
मैंने आपको क्लियर कर दिया मतलब की ई
टैग ई टैग इसको समझिए ई टैग स्पेसिफाई एन
एंटिटी टैग ये सर्वर रिस्पांस डर की मैं
है मैं की हेडर है बट मैं आपको थोड़ा पहले
ही बता रहा हूं ताकि आपको यह दोनों क्लियर
हो जाए ई टैग के थ्रू सर्वर एंटिटी टैग जो
है स्पेसिफाई करता है क्लाइंट कैन सबमिट
दिस आइडेंटिफिकेशन
फ्यूचर रिक्वेस्ट फॉर द सेम रिसोर्स इन द
इफ नॉन मैच हेडर टू नोटिफाई द सर्वर च
वर्जन ऑफ द रिसोर्स द ब्राउजर करेंटली
होल्ड्स इन इट्स कैश मतलब कि ब्राउजर इफ
नॉन मैच के
थ्रू बताता है कि कौन सा वर्जन उसके पास
है कैस्ट कॉपी का उस पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स के
लिए बस सिंपल सा फंडा
है ठीक है इतना बहुत ही क्लियर क्लियर चीज
है बहुत ही क्लियर चीज है बट मैं आपको
थोड़ा सा यहां पे समझा देता हूं सर्वर जो
है वो ई
टैग ई टैग रिस्पांस हेडर के
थ्रू रिस्पांस हेडर के थ्रू क्या करता है
यह सर्वर ईटेक रिस्पांस डर के थ्रू यहां
पे स्पेसिफाई एटी क्लाइंट्स कैन सबमिट दिस
फ्यूचर फॉर द सेम रिसोर्स न मै यहां पे वज
ऑ द रिसोर्स ब्राउजर करेंटली होल्ड्स तो ई
टैग के थ्रू एंटिटी टैग के थ्रू
सर्वर जो है बेसिकली यहां पर जो आप देख
रहे होंगे कि यूजिंग य न द सर्वर कैन यूज
द एंटिटी टक टू डिटरमाइंड वेदर द ब्राउजर
मे यूज कैच कॉपी ऑफ द रिसोर्सेस यानी कि
ईटेक के थ्रू सर्वर बताता है कि ब्राउजर
रिस्पांस जो ब्राउजर है वह कैस्ट कॉपी को
यूज कर सकता है या नहीं कैस्ट कॉपी
को यूज और कैन नॉट
बी कैन नॉट बी यूज कर सकता है कि नहीं एंड
इसी का रिस्पांस क्लाइंट जो है इफ नॉन
मैच इफ नॉन मैच के थ्रू आपको देता है जो
कि क्या देता है यहां पर इफ नॉन मैच के
थ्रू इफ नॉन मैच जो कि उसी एंटिटी टैग का
रिप्लाई एक तरह से बोल सकते हो रिप्लाई है
सिंपल चच इज एन आईडेंटिफाइड नोट कंटेंट
ब्राउजर सबमिट एंटिटी टैग ट द सर्वर इशू
विद द रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स वन इट वाज
लास्ट
रिसीव ठीक है एंड सर्वर यूज करता है
एंटिटी टैग का टू मा वेदर द ब्राउजर मे
यूज इट्स कैस्ट कॉपी और नॉट एस सिंपल एट
ठीक है बस यही डिफरेंस है यही चीज होती है
एंटिटी ई टैग एंड इफ नॉन मैच के बीच में
अब इफ मॉडिफाइड सेंस से क्या होता है
ब्राउजर को कब वो लास्ट रिसोर्स
रिक्वेस्टेड रिसोर्स मिली थी एंड अगर वो
रिसोर्स चेंज नहीं हुआ है तो भैया सर्वर
बोलता है कि आप कैस्ट कॉपी का यूज करो एंड
इसके थ्रू मैसेज इफ नॉन मैच के थ्रू बताता
है कि भैया कौन सा वर्जन आपके पास
है ठीक है कौन सा वर्जन मतलब आप यूज कर
रहे स्पेसिफाई यहां पर फॉर द सेम रिसोर्स
इफ नॉन मैच है टू नोटिफाई द सर्वर मतलब इफ
नॉन मैच जो है वही बताता है कि कौन सा
वर्जन रिसोर्स का आपके पास है तो मतलब
क्या हुआ ई टैग के थ्रू सर्वर ने पूछा
क्लाइंट से सवर ने बताया क्लाइंट क्लाइंट
को क्या बताता है एक ई टैग भेजता है
एंटिटी टैग
आइडेंटिफिकेशन मेरे पास जो रिसोर्स अभी
मैं यूज मेरे पास प्रेजेंट है वो वर्जन वन
है एंड अगर वो रिसोर्स सेम वर्जन वन है
सर्वर पे सेम रिसोर्स चेंज नहीं हुआ है तो
यह कैज कॉपी को यूज कर सकता है आपका
ब्राउजर क्लाइंट उसी से रिट्राईंग रिसोर्स
को बट अगर ये सर्वर पे वर्जन 1.2 आ चुका
है एंड इसके पास कैश कॉपी वन ही है तो
रिक्वेस्ट दोबारा से जाएगी सर्वर के पास
एंड सर्वर उसको फिर रिप्लाई करेगा वर्जन
1.2 वाले रिसोर्स के साथ एंड देन उसको वो
कैश कॉपी में डालेगा कैश मेमोरी में एंड
देन अगली बार से जब रिसोर्स को रिक्वेस्ट
करेगा तो 1.2 वाले वर्जन को रिक्वेस्ट
करने के लिए सर्वर के पास फिर से नहीं
जाना होगा क्योंकि कैश मेमोरी में ऑलरेडी
होगी तो वहीं से एक्सेस कर लेगा सज सिंपल
एज दैट बस कहानी खत्म समझ में आ गया
सबको अ एवरीवन गेटिंग सर आई हैव हैकर रैंक
ऑन हैक द बॉक्स प्लेटफॉर्म जस्ट सॉ योर
प्लेलिस्ट दे आर लाइक एन एडिक्शन लाइक अ
वेब सीरीज आई हैव कंप्लीटेड ऑल इन टू डेज
रियली अप्रिशिएट इड थैंक यू प्रक प्रुक
ओके थैंक यू सो मच ग्लैड टू नो दैट गाइस
एंड आप लोग जो भी कर रहे हैं जो भी
सिंसियर कर रहे हैं इसको फॉलो प्लेलिस्ट
को सो रियली आई एम वेरी ग्लैड गाइस कि आप
लोग इस तरह का सिंसियर दिखा रहे हैं एंड
थैंक यू प्रॉक्सी थैंक यू सो मच तो ये
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
राइट
चलिए
सॉरी क्लास नाइंथ लर्नर ओ वेलकम बहुत
बढ़िया तो ये इफ नॉन मैच आ गया अब आते हैं
ओरिजिन इज यूज टू क्रॉस डोमेन एजेक्स
रिक्वेस्ट टू इंडिकेट द डोमेन फ्रॉम विच द
रिक्वेस्ट इज ओरिजनेटेड तो यह बेसिकली
ओरिजिन जो टैब है यह क्रॉस
डोमेन ओरिजिन क्रॉस डोमेन एंटिटी को शो
करने के लिए है जैसे कि आप कौन से
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन का यूज हम कर रहे हैं
लाइक रिक्वेस्ट करने के लिए उसके लिए
ओरिजिन यहां पर आपको स्पेसिफाई की जाती है
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के अंदर ठीक है तो आपका यह
हो सकता है पॉसिबिलिटी कि आपने यहां पर
आपका होस्ट नेम कुछ और हो एंड आपका ओरिजिन
कुछ और हो ठीक है तो एक सवा प दो
वेबसाइट्स है तो यह पॉसिबिलिटी है कि आपका
जो रिक्वेस्ट ओरिजिन है वह कुछ और हो सकता
है कोई और डोमेन हो सकती है तो दिस इज
कॉल्ड
ओरिजिन ठीक
है स्टडी विद मी थैंक यू
वेलकम डीजे कहां गया डीजे का पता नहीं
यार चलिए सॉरी फॉर द डिस्टरबेंसस यहां प
थोड़ी सी गले में प्रॉब्लम है अब यहां प
ओरिजिन के बाद यहां पे ओरिजिन आपका यह रहा
कि कौन सा पर्टिकुलर ओरिजिन सर्वर जो है
इसको एक्सेस कर रहा है कौन से ओरिजिन
सर्वर का यूज कर रहे हैं हम पर्टिकुलर
रिसोर्स को एक्सेस करने के लिए ठीक है अब
आते है रेफरर स्पेसिफाई द यूआरएल फ्रॉम
विच द करंट रिक्वेस्ट ओरिजनेटेड जो अभी
करंट रिक्वेस्ट है जैसे अभी एक अभी क्या
है यह करंट रिक्वेस्ट है यह जो रिक्वेस्ट
है आपका यह वाला मैं इसको यह रिक्वेस्ट यह
करंट रिक्वेस्ट है तो यह कहां से पता चलता
है यह आपके बेसिकली रेफरर जो हेडर है आपका
यह वाला यहां से पता चलता है कि कहां से
कहां से ओरिजनेट हुआ है टेस्ट ph1 web.com
login.php लॉगइन पीएपी इस पाथ ने इस
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड किया है एंड
जो कि ओरिजिन सर्वर हमारे टेस्ट ph1
web.com से आया हुआ है
एसे ओके चलिए ये तो समझ में आ गया आपको
रेफर अब आते हैं यूजर एेंट यह क्या होता
है प्रोवाइड्स इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट द ब्राउजर
और अदर क्लाइंट सॉफ्टवेयर दैट जनरेट द
रिक्वेस्ट सिंपल सा फंडा है यूजर एजेंट के
अंदर ब्राउजर हेडर्स होते हैं ब्राउजर की
इंफॉर्मेशन होती है ब्राउजर के बारे में
यहां पे जानकारी होती है जो कि आपको यूजर
एेंट में मिलता है जैसे यहां पे आपको दिख
रहा होगा कि
ब्रैकेट में विंडोज
एंटी जो फैमिली है उसकी विंडोज यूज हो रही
है 64 बिट विंडोज यहां पे यूज हो रहा है
तो ये सारे ऑप्शन ये जो चीजें है यह आपको
बताता है सिंपल एंड firefox.exe
कंट्रोल अलाउ ओरिजिन इसके बारे में आई
थिंक मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको बताया हुआ है
एक्सेस कंट्रोल अलाउ ओरिजिन के बारे में
मैंने जब आपको सीएसपी की क्लास आपकी जो
वीडियो थी तो आपसे रिक्वेस्ट इसलिए मैं
बोलता हूं हर एक वीडियो को आप देखिए वो
आपके लिए बढ़िया रहेगा हर एक वीडियो जितनी
वीडियोस देखेंगे बढ़िया रहेगा तो जब आप
हमारे बग बाउंट सीरीज में लाइव में आएंगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे मैंने यहां पर एक
वीडियो यहां पर डाली हुई थी एंड दिस
वीडियो
वाज
आई थिंक ये वीडियो सेक्शन में आएगा आपको
वीडियो सेक्शन में आ जाइएगा एक्सप्लेंड
सीओ आरएस एंड सीएसपी इसके अंदर मैंने आपको
एक्सेस कंट्रोल अलाउ ओरिजिन के बारे में
बताया था कि एक्सेस कंट्रोल जो कि ओरिजिन
अलाउ ओरिजिन यानी कि ओरिजिन को अलाउ करता
है करेंगे करना है कि नहीं करना है कौन सी
ओरिजिन किस टाइप का ओरिजिन अलाउड है क्या
है वो सब बताता है इंडिकेट्स वेदर द
रिसोर्स कैन बी ट्राइव बाय क्रॉस डोमेन एस
रिक्वेस्ट मतलब इसके थ्रू आप यह बताते हैं
कि अगर यह मान लो अलाउड होता है बाय चांस
अलाउ ओरिजिन वहां पे तो कोई भी ओरिजिन
सर्वर जो है उस पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को
एक्सेस कर सकती है रिसोर्स को एक्सेस कर
सकती है जो कि कहीं से भी कहीं से भी सेफ
नहीं है अनसेफ है तो ऐसा नहीं होना चाहिए
ओके उसके बाद आ है कैश
कंट्रोल पासेस द कैशिंग डायरेक्टिव्स टू द
ब्राउजर फॉर एग्जांपल नो कैश मतलब यह
बताता है कि भैया इस पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स को
आपको कैश करना है कि नहीं करना है कैश कर
सकते हैं कि नहीं कर सकते यह बताता है कैश
कंट्रोल ठीक है यहां पर अगर होगा तो आप
देख सकते हैं नहीं होगा तो कोई बात नहीं
यहां प कैश रो लेट्स सी दे इ नो ओके सॉरी
यहां पे आएगा रिपस टर में सो कनेक्शन
एक्सपर्ट बाय नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग कुछ नहीं
यहां पे यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ आपका होगा
क्योंकि ये कंटेंट यहां पे दिया हुआ मैसेज
बॉडी में इसलिए कंटेंट लेंथ 5963 यहां ठीक
है तो बेसिकली कैश कंट्रोल आपका क्या करता
है बताता है कि ब्राउजर को इंस्ट्रक्ट
करता है सर्वर कि भैया कैश करो या नहीं
करो क्या है नो कैश करो किस तरीके से सब
बताता है उसके बाद ई टैग जो मैंने अभी बात
की सेम वही चीजें हैं बस ट्स इट
स्पेसिफाई द एंटिटी टैग जो सर्वर एंटिटी
टैग स्पेसिफाई करता है क्लाइंट्स क सबमिट
दिस
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कैस्ट कॉपी का मेरे पास है सेम वर्जन है
तो ठीक है मैं उसी से उठा लूंगा नहीं है
तो भैया दोबारा रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा आपको
मेरे को दोबारा उस रिसोर्स को देना है
सिंपल एक्सपायर्स टेल्स द ब्राउजर फॉर हाउ
लॉन्ग द कंटेंट्स ऑफ द मैसेज बॉडी आर
वैलिड मतलब मैसेज बॉडी का कंटेंट है मान
लो यह मैसेज बॉडी का कंटेंट है यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा है ये कंटेंट है अब यह
कंटेंट कब एक्सपायर होगा कितने टाइम तक
एक्सपायर होगा कितने टाइम में एक्सपायर
होगा यह बताता है हमारा एक्सपायर्स
रिस्पांस डर उसके बाद आता है लोकेशन इट इज
यूज्ड इन रीडायरेक्शन रीडायरेक्शन
रिस्पांसस दोज दैट हैव अ स्टेटस स् कोड
स्टार्टिंग विद थ्री यानी 3x वाले स्टेटस
कोड जितने होते हैं व डायरेक्शन में यूज़
होते हैं तो उसके रीडायरेक्शन रिस्पांस के
लिए ये यूज़ में लिया जाता है टू
स्पेसिफाई द टारगेट ऑफ द रीडायरेक्ट मतलब
कहां पे रीडायरेक्ट करना है प्रग्मा पासेस
कैशिंग डायरेक्टिव्स टू द ब्राउजर प्रग्मा
जो है ना वो कैशिंग डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
यूज्ड ठीक है अब यहां पे दो और हेडर्स की
यहां पे बात हो रही है बेसिकली ये अलग-अलग
हेडर्स है ठीक है ये दोनों अलग-अलग हेडर
पगमा एक अलग यहां पर रिस्पांस हेडर है एंड
यहां पर सर्वर जो है एक अलग रिस्पांस हेडर
है ये दोनों डिफरेंट है जैसे कि मैं यहां
पर दिखा देता हूं
आपको दिस वनस वन नीचे आते है रिक्वेस्टर
में यह रही रिस्पांस हेडर में तो यहां पर
यह जो प्रग्मा है दिस इज अ डिफरेंट हेडर
रिस्पांस हेडर एंड यह सर्वर जो है ये
डिफरेंट रिस्प डर है ठीक है यहां पर शायद
थोड़ा
सा
जूम कर सकते
हैं तो चलिए यह तो मैंने आपको बता दिया
सिंपल अब मैं आप समझ लीजिएगा य पे पगमा जो
है हेडर है यह कैशिंग डायरेक्टिव यह भी
पास करता है बेसिकली तो कैश कंट्रोल है
प्रग्मा है ये दोनों कैशिंग डायरेक्टिव्स
पास करते हैं ब्राउजर को बताते हैं कैशिंग
का एंड सर्वर हेडर जो है बेसिकली जो
रिस्पांस ट सर्वर वाला है यहां पे ये जैसे
सर्वर है ये सर्वर की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देता है कि कौन सा यूज हो रहा है जैसे
यहां पर ए जिंस वर्जन
1.19.0 यूज हो रहा है तो सर्वर के बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन देता है ठीक है उसके बाद
आती है सेट कुकी सेट कुकी आते हू मैं आपके
सारी बातें आपकी जो भी है उस पर
आएंगे सेट कुकी इशू द कुकीज टू द ब्राउजर
दैट इट विल सबमिट बैक टू द सर्वर इन
सबसीक्वेंट रिक्वेस्ट सेट कुकी के थ्रू ही
सर्वर कुकी को सेट करता है कुकीज इश्यूज
करता है जिसको कि कुकी नाम के रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर में से रिप्लाई करता है हमा हमारा स
क्लाइंट ये वाली कुकी हेडर रिक्वेस्ट हेडर
के थ्रू तो रिस्पांस हेडर में पहले आपका
सेट कुकी जाता है ड्ड ऑथेंटिकेट ये क्या
कहता है इट इज यूज टू रेप इन रिस्पांस दैट
हैव अ 401 स्टेटस कोड टू प्रोवाइड डिटेल्स
ऑन द टाइप ऑफ ऑथेंटिकेशन दैट द सर्वर
सपोर्ट्स मतलब कोई ऐसा पेज है जो 401
स्टेटस कोड दे रहा है तो उसकी डिटेल के
लिए लाइक कौन सा टाइप का ऑथेंटिकेशन जो है
सर्वर सपोर्ट करता है पर्टिकुलर उसके लिए
यह ड्ड ऑथेंटिकेट रिस्पांस ड यूज में लिया
जाता है एज सिंपल एक्स फ्रेम ऑप्शंस
इंडिकेट्स वेदर द एंड हाउ द करंट रिस्पांस
मे बी लोडेड विद इन अ ब्राउजर फ्रेम
बेसिकली क्लिक
जैकिंग जैसे अटैक्स से बचाने के लिए एटीएल
इंजेक्शन अटैक से बचाने के लिए एक्स फ्रेम
ऑप्शंस का कई बार यूज किया जाता है जो कि
बताता है कि कैसे पर्टिकुलर उस वो प अभी
करंट जो रिस्पांस जो है करंट जो रिस्पांस
सवर को देना है वह किस तरीके से लोड होगा
एक ब्राउजर फ्रेम में लोड होगा नहीं होगा
किस तरीके से लोड होगा वो बताया जाता है
एक्सफेम ऑप्शंस की तरफ से तो ये कुछ
रिस्पांस हेडर्स थे एंड इसके पहले हमने
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स देखा उसके पहले हमने कुछ
जनरल हेडर्स देखा उसके पहले हमने एसटीडीपी
मेथड्स के बारे में यहां पे देखा देन हमने
यहां पे यह और भी कुछ हेडर्स जो है वो
हमने देखे यहां पे प्रैग्मा मैंने वही
बताया इंस्ट्रक्ट द ब्राउजर नॉट टू स्टोर
द रिस्पांस इन इट्स कैस्ट प्रैग्मा जो
बताता है क्या बताता है इंस्ट्रक्ट द
ब्राउजर नॉट टू स्टोर द रिस्पांस इन इट्स
कैश द एक्सपायर्स हेडर इंडिकेट दैट द
रिस्पांस कंटेंट एक्सपायर्ड इन द पास्ट
देयर फोर शुड नॉट बी कैस्ट बस ये चीजें
बताता है सेट कुकीज आपका ये सब कुछ हमने
देखा हमने रिस्पांस ड रिक्वेस्ट ड हमने
एसटीटीपी रिस्पांस कैसा होता है वो देखा
एसटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट कैसा होता है वो देखा
तो बेसिकली हमने सारी चीजें आज की क्लास
में समझी अब क्या-क्या चीजें समझा पहले एक
बार जल्दी से मैं थोड़ा सा रीकैप यहां पे
कर देता हूं जो हमने यहां पे आज की क्लास
में देखा है तो आज की क्लास में हमने
एसटीटीपी के बारे में पहले हमने देखा क्या
होता है
एचटीटीपीएस एंड एसएसएल के बारे में हमने
थोड़ा सा देखा यहां पे उसके बाद हमने यहां
पे
एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के बारे में यहां पे हमने
पढ़ा उसके बाद हमने रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स के
बारे में पढ़ा उसके बाद हमने रिस्पांस
हेडर के बारे में
पढ़ा ठीक
है उसके बाद हमने यहां पे जनरल हेडर्स के
बारे में पढ़ा आज की क्लास में जनरल
हेडर्स कौन-कौन से होते हैं उसके बाद हमने
एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के बारे में पढ़ा
यह सारी चीजें आज की क्लास में हमने कवर
की ये सारे कांसेप्ट हमने कवर कि एंड आई
होप कि आपको अब यह कांसेप्ट क्लियर हो गए
होंगे समझ में आ गया होगा बट स्टिल मैं
आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि यह जो मैंने
आपको बताया सिर्फ इतनी ही नहीं है यह इनोस
दिस आर ओसस इन टॉपिक्स पे आप पूरा बुक पढ़
सकते हो यह टॉपिक्स सेल्फ एक्सप्लोर
एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए बनी हुई है तो
एचटीटीपी एचटीटीपी के बारे में मेथड्स के
बारे में रिक्वेस्ट है डर्स रिस्पांस डर्स
के बारे में और भी डिटेल में मैं आपको
रिकमेंड करूंगा कि आप पढ़िए इंटरनेट पे सब
कुछ मिल जाएगा और एक्सप्लोर कीजिए बहुत
कुछ और जूसी इंफॉर्मेशन बहुत सारी चीजें
मिलेंगी जो आपके बग बाउंट जर्नी में बहुत
हेल्प करने वाली है बहुत ज्यादा अभी मैं
आपको बताऊंगा बहुत सारे बग्स को आप हेडर्स
के अंदर इंजेक्शन करके कुछ मिस कॉन्फिन का
यूज करके आप वो बग्स फाइंड कर सकते हैं
हेडर्स के अंदर राइट तो यह बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट था इसलिए एंड आप लोगों ने इस
क्लास के लिए पहले क्लास में बोला हुआ था
कि सर एसटीटीपी के ऊपर क्लास लाइए
एसटीटीपी के ऊपर बताइए एटीटीपी हेडर्स के
बारे में बताइए रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के बारे
में इन सब के बारे में बताइए
दैट्ची भी आ जाए या जो भी है तो पूरी हम
देखेंगे बहुत अच्छे से उसको करेंगे लाइव
भी करेंगे सब कुछ ठीक
है
ओके ओके नेक्स्ट वीडियो जल्दी थैंक यू
थैंक
यू सर के सीओ आरएस हां जी सीओ आरएस वाली
वीडियो जरूर देख लेना आप लोग सीओ आरएस एंड
सीएसपी वाले ठीक है वेलकम
वेलकम
चलो ओके चलो तो अभी सभी लोग क्या है जाते
टाइम लाइक ठोक के जाना यार लाइक्स यार अभी
सिर्फ 80 लाइक्स हैं 100 भी नहीं हुए आज
तो यार ये तो नाइन साफी हो गई तो 100
लाइक्स पूरी करके ही जाना सभी मुझे पता है
आराम से हो जाएगा सो प्लीज यार लाइक तो
ठोकना भाई लाइक नहीं ठोको ग तो नहीं काम
चलेगा लाइक तो ठोकना
पड़ेगा ठीक है सर आई सबमिटेड अ रिपोर्ट इन
हैकर वन क्लोज द रिपोर्ट एंड चेंज द
इंफॉर्मेशन टू इनफॉर्मेटिव बट सेंड अ
कांग्रेचुलेशन वैलिड बग मेल टुडे आई कांट
अंडरस्टैंड व्हाई दे सेंड द मेल अरे भैया
तो मेल तो भेजेंगे ना वैलिड बग था आपका वो
इनफॉर्मेटिव था क्योंकि कोई उसका खास
इंपैक्ट नहीं था तो वो इनफॉर्मेटिव क्लोज
कर दिया आपका उसके लिए कोई रिवॉर्ड हॉल ऑफ
फेम नहीं मिलेगा बट वो वैलिड बग था इसके
लिए आपको कांग्रेचुलेशन वहां पे प्रोवाइड
दिया गया आपको इनकरेज करने के लिए ठीक है
सो कांग्रेचुलेशन फ्रॉम होल डेफॉक्स टीम
आल्सो एंड फ्रॉम माय साइड
आल्सो ठीक है नेक्स्ट वीडियो जल्दी आएगी
भाई जल्दी आएगी टेंशन मत लो थैंक यू लाइक
थैंक यू सो
मच ओके तो अब आपका यह वाला जो यह वाली जो
आपकी गुत्थी है सॉल्व हो गई होगी यह वाली
जो यह सब जो आप देख रहे होंगे यह सब क्या
है यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा यह सब जो
आप देखते थे अरे भाईया ये सब क्या है ये
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा सारी चीजें एंड
जब हम फ्यूचर में और भी क्लासेस करेंगे तो
उसमें हम रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर का
बहुत फ्रीक्वेंसी
क्लास कुछ एक डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ लेबिलिटी
के ऊपर बहुत शानदार होने वाली है तो आ
जाना उस क्लास में ठीक है ठीक है
सर डि फोनिक्स में कंटेंट राइटर के लिए
इंटर्नशिप कर सकता हूं डीसी जीएसपी
स्टूडेंट पल्लव ओके आप प्लीज मुझे t ग्रा
प कांटेक्ट कर लीजिएगा पल्लव ठीक है प्लीज
प्लीज कांटेक्ट ऑन टेलीग्राम
राइट चलिए टास्क सिंपल सा एक ही टास्क मैं
आपको देता हूं वही टास्क हमेशा के लिए
होता है कि जो आपको कराया है मैंने उसको
पूरा का पूरा रिवाइज कीजिए जो मैंने आज
क्लासेस में कराई है एंड उसको एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए कोई भी टीचर ट्रेनर या गाइडेंस गाइड
गाइड या मेंटर आपको बोलता है कि जो मैंने
पढ़ाया बस उतना ही पढ़ लो उतना ही काफी है
यह फिर बहुत बड़ा झूठ होता है नहीं कोई भी
चीज उतनी काफी नहीं होती है उसको सेल्फ
एक्सप्लोर करोगे तभी उसमें बेस्ट बन पाओगे
कांसेप्ट का कोई एंड नहीं होता सीखने का
तो उसको सीखो एक्सप्लोर करो एंड एक
रिक्वेस्ट बस यह है कि जितने भी वीडियोस
हैं भैया हमारे बग बाउंटीज के सबको
कंप्लीट मारो एंड यार
क बार बोला है मैंने
linked-list
यहां पर किसी ने शायद यस किसी ने टैक किया
हुआ है ठीक है वो तो हम देख लेंगे बट ये
चीज आप कीजिए एंड फॉलो कीजिए यहां पे यहां
पे हमारा बेसिकली t पेज को फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है तो लाइक ठोकते हुए जाना 88
लाइक्स हो गए हैं 100 तो नहीं हो पाएंगे
शायद 89 हो चुके हैं तो आई डोंट नो 100 हो
पाएंगे कि नहीं बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
थैंक यू सो मच गाइस एंड फॉर जॉइनिंग द
क्लास एंड इतना सपोर्ट प्यार दिखाने के
लिए बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद एंड ऐसी कंटेंट आती
रहेगी टेंशन मत लो बंग
बहुत जल्द खत्म नहीं होने वाली है यह
थोड़ा लंबा चलेगा क्योंकि आपको वह कंटेंट
देना है जो पेड कोर्स में भी नहीं मिलते
बस इतना मुझे पता है सो कीप ऑन हैंगिंग इन
दिस क्लासेस एंड वी विल मीट इन द नेक्स्ट
क्लास थैंक यू सो मच गाइस एंड गुड
नाइट